hey everyone so i'm in the process of
editing part two of the autumn marathon
i played
well over 12 hours of the tournament
part one is already on my youtube
channel it's this one right here
uh the first hour
this video is probably gonna be over in
half hours
so it's gonna take a long time to render
i'm hoping to get this out asap
and i really hope you enjoy it i played
a lot of like really fun games and cool
gambits
so i'm going to time stamp every single
game in the video description there
should be chapters on a youtube player
so if you want to hop around and
look at all the different crazy openings
i played feel free to do so
and enjoy the video
okay berserking again
[Music]
a lot of sicilian players today
oh that was a mouse slip
i meant to take
oh it's an accidental sicilian gambit
okay i'll add on cloud
some people saying bong clown
let's try and make the most of this
oh yeah also non-sicilian players
hope everyone has a good day
this position already looks pretty fun
wow does this move
let's take this
black's asking for trouble
e6
uh am i meeting
seems close to mate
g4
running maiden one
okay that was pleasant
i turned a mouse slip into like a really
nice gambit
i guess the pawn here actually really
helped
it
allowed for e6
here
okay the mouse slip gambit i'll add that
to the accomplished list
okay let's go
i'm still down raiding right
i'm down nine points
from that one loss
but okay i have 51 tournament points
leader has 172. that's crazy
i'm almost almost out of tea too
oh no my tea
hey it's emo only mode
okay
emo only mode for the duration of this
game
look at the stafford
or play for a stafford
i'm trying to win as quickly as possible
so chat doesn't have to
stay too long in emo homie mode
yeah so in these sort of like
symmetrical italian positions i like to
go for the early g5
g4 etc
it's risky but it's also fun
hitting the bishop
one takes i probably take with knight
while
on croissant
f4 is very nifty
taking only helps
white open the file
oh what else to do
actually a great move
i'm gonna knot off a son
and the karma gods might attack me
or the anarchy chess cults might attack
me but that's okay
i just want to meet
[Music]
okay
wait i could have taken the bishop
what was i thinking
what was white thinking i can still take
the bishop
hey it's made in two rogue f2 takes and
then meets
okay
i hope people can forgive me for not
taking on poisson
it was worth it
was i worse i was probably much worse
after f4
can't wait for quaid variation fireworks
coming
yeah i've been trying every game
oh knight c6 best move
oh or not
dogfish prefers on poisson
really it's tied though
i was scared of uh
oh what was i scared of
for some reason i was scared of queen f3
but i just take
i was seeing ghosts
okay back to tournament
disabling emote only mode
thank you lockheed for the
w bits
i haven't had a buddha pass this stream
hey it's budapest gambit time
i'll play the line with d6 takes in
queen f6
itself online
oh or this line so if knight takes i
play queen d4
working all the things
i think i have to take the bishop here
i could take the knight but
okay what is this position
this move is maybe
coming maybe this move
i mean mike can still play this and try
and fork me
there's a funny line this and then takes
john davis just destroyed me in a vienna
greek gift opening trap
[Music]
vienna greek gift
i have to add that to the bucket list
also what is
g3 also i have to move quicker
i was hoping for some mating ideas
against f2 but
i have to be patient here
and now this is a real possibility
if knight d5 i probably just castle
i mean there's a line knight d5 castling
takes and then queen b6
defending the knight and mate or queen
c6
threaten the knight in the rook
looks like white might be casting queen
side
i mean now my plan is night here
etc
in rookie 8
knight is looking very tender
so 95
still play this move hitting the queen
that doesn't work
okay
not exactly what i wanted
but trying to make this work
my things are hanging
okay so if takes i have this and then
takes a queen
28 seconds
ah gotta focus again
if either castling i have the check to
win the queen
getting merch i blundered and broke my
last mug oh no
oh i guess you can get a new mug
cheers
the mugs are sturdy as long as you don't
like throw them against a wall
or down a flight of stairs
they hold a decent amount of tea
[Music]
okay let's play this and
yeah it's tricky position
[Music]
the snow i don't have that move
i'm in trouble here
ah i'm in a lot of trouble
oh my king
oh i got a little bit careless there
yeah i mean i sense a danger it's just
like what to do because the rook's
hanging
maybe i should have played this first
leave the tension
the back rank was a big issue
i wanted to play this but of course just
knight takes
good game well played
that was a failed budapest
that was a weird line too knight e3
wonder if there's a way to punish
yeah just castling
uh so calcium keeping the pin and
probably preparing rook t8 would be
a bit more
tricky for whites
okay
awesome learned
oh know some people's channel points
so no berserking this time or do i
berserk
nope is working
i want to quite variation anytime i lose
i'll
i'll play one game to just cool down and
recover from the
the twilt the tilt
let's play a classic modern
the line i usually like to go for here
is queen e2
[Music]
and if knight f6 then i'll go for e5
if that move
just reinforcings
and this is a very typical trap
maybe i should have berserked i've given
this
opening yeah if king jig's bishop i had
knight g5 to win the bishop
okay
definitely want to keep this light
squared bishop
my best piece
i'll be threatening e5 now
winning connect 4 and winning material
this whole diagonal is occupied
also it's almost mating
now the rook is trapped
if takes i mate
yeah this game is like one big
practical avalanche
might be losing back a couple pawns
but okay i'm up a rook for a pawn
probably want to pressure the bishop
work some stuff
too many options
eventually i'll take or maybe i'll go
for g5
oh
okay making things spicy
do i have g5 made on my bucket list
g5 mate okay let's try and get g5 mates
but how to do it
i need to control h5
which would require
wow very impressive eric
oh thank you
uh how do i get g5 made it's not so
simple
i'll play this move
and now maybe takes
doesn't really work though
i'm just trying to complete a bucket
list item
maybe i'll start with h4
and there's an idea to play h4 bishop
five takes and then g5 mate
uh
i'm also just looking for mate in
okay maybe i'll take here
oh i have an idea okay so
my plan is to
eventually play h4 knight f5 takes and
then g5 mate
don't resign
ah the king's walking up
what is this
i am an entire day ahead of you
midwesterner
okay
i want to play h4 eventually
it's a confusing position
at some point i should probably just
meet normally
and the king can go back or take
if it went back i would have had a clear
g5 mate
let's take here
okay no g5 mates
we'll have knight d5 me how about
okay
yeah there were like a bunch of
different meets this has been a very
nice game
how you handle the opening gives me some
good ideas to use against the modern oh
yeah the i mean
it's a nice line because it's a it's a
bit trappy
there's actually a few traps from this
move order
one of which we saw bishop g4 too early
and takes in knight g5 is nice
the other trap that some people fall for
is
[Music]
a 97
which walks into takes takes and knight
g5
if this or this the queen is lost
queen would be trapped or there's a fork
or if king f6
which 1260 people have played
and queen f3 has made
have i had this before
i had this once before
i've only played king e8
that's a fun line
thank you lockheed
for the more w bits
okay less than 20 hours left
lost two games so far
the top 200.
do i berserk i think i'm berserk i won
that last game
my opponent is not berking back
oh this is kind of risky
i have to say focus this game
welcoming a stafford
oh white's playing very solidly
i don't want to get too low on time too
quickly
it's already getting interesting
hey thank you lebloski for the raid
if you're just joining i i'm just
working a decently high rated player
so i have to stay somewhat focused
this pawn's a bit tender
i might be threatening this move
oh that's a good move though
i'm just worse here
but still
alive maybe f6 at some point
also c5 ideas
going after the pawn
workout four i think i play queen g5
go for the queen trade
even rookie two
you're going for the queen trade
so if takes i take back and when the
win the pawn because the rook doesn't
have any squares
defend this
i mean g5 might be a resource
i'll look to play knight g6
very tense position
[Music]
now d5 might be falling
[Music]
a little bit scared here
yeah
i'm scared of that
what's so clear though
i can't play rook c2 so queen defends
from a distance
in this move
it's not over
a really difficult position though
running to take
no i'm not cause this
i guess my king could run this way
potentially
this is really terrifying
i'm up two exchanges
for bishop knight coupons
what is this
[Music]
oh no
i might just be dead here
yeah i'm just losing
i believe
i was expecting that d5
probably just worth resigning but you
never know
that's a good move
i cut my king off
oh no okay i resign
so there's a move i wanted to play
which was
so in this position
this position
i really wanted to take here
the problem is white's just mating after
this this this
and white's up 28 pawns
what is this
oh i was alive for a moment rook d4
ah threatening rook d2
[Music]
it's such a scary position though
and then here i had queen f7
yeah requires like very precise play
okay
no berserking next game
still top 200
that's my third loss
it's gonna take work longer the
tournament goes
the harder it will be to climb
[Music]
um
oh let's go for the codas
what is zakatas
c6
or knight f6 i think i have six
d4 and then c6
okay knight c3 i just uh play normal
chess
oh joe's saying what the goddess is but
oh it's too late now
yeah normally if i start a game i'm not
gonna
like look at the chat for opening
suggestions or
what the opening line is
that's something to do between games
oh axe for typo
this is something i'll look at during
the game
ultra marathoner
is the most playable 15-letter word in
scrabble
ah because you can extend marathon or
ultra
oh that's kind of cool
i an ultra marathoner
depends how long i can last in this
[Music]
tournament i wouldn't mind getting the
bishop here
yeah the one thing to watch out for is
a4 i think after king b7 things are fine
i'm still looking to go for e5 or g5
it's also nice having a lot of time
to deliberate
have the increments
it would be cool to do an ultra bullet
marathon
but also like really exhausting
i guess if i did an ultra bullet
marathon then
i would be more of an ultra marathoner
okay pawns are smiling
very positional game so far
i want to go for h5
kingside pawn storm
maybe some night maneuver
yeah let's get some smileys in the chat
for my pawns they're so happy
oh
white wants to make them unhappy
but here okay i can
can smile some more this is a more
asymmetrical smile
chad is so happy now
perhaps some smaller ultra bullet
tournaments first to build one's stamina
that's true yeah i played a decent
amount of ultra bullets
in the last 24 hours
probably not the healthiest for my wrist
bones or wrist muscles
i played this move
i'm just going for the squeeze
preventing
white from castling
there's a funny line
imagine like h5 king b7 then castling i
could take here
takes and then rook c8
um
[Music]
i might as well try and set it up
so basically threatening now this move
i mean knight f1 might be played
or that
we might have to trade
don't really want to trade
i guess i have to
threatening this
make sure you get adequate rest and
throw in some protein shakes after your
sessions yeah that's good that last part
was a bit of a joke
wait really
i thought that's good advice to throw in
some protein shakes or just some like
energy
energy bar type thing
sometimes jokes can be taken seriously
i actually have do i have my bar i do
have my bar
i ate my bar
i was eating this uh
this you can energy bar
it's made for olympic athletes
or like endurance and focus
the company sent me like a huge gift box
of my subscription is born
love you long time
oh i love you too long time
thank you slim stacy
subbing for nine months
thirty months i remember life before the
connect four remote
wow yeah there's different things that
have popped up over time
over the last 30 months
welcome back lord francesco
actually i consumed this right before
the stream so hopefully it gives me some
prolonged energy
i'm not sponsored by them no
uh maybe someday but it was nice for
them to
to send some some product to try
lockheed with the early w bits yeah my
opponent is very low on time
but the position is not winning yet
trying to poken prod
i mean white's playing very solidly
i'll put my king here
maybe
yeah let's go for this
idea king e6 and then eventually d4
ooh
[Music]
not so simple
we trade
i have to do something about this
tension
i don't think taking is winning
and this move
also might be troublesome
maybe i'll take first
let's take first because there's a
there's a funny line
it takes
[Music]
okay maybe now i take
[Music]
okay we'll trade everything
not what i wanted given the time
situation but
my king has a clear path
a heaven
it's still tricky
in this move
positional sacrifice to get the king
here
okay there goes the pawn
here goes another pawn oh i was about to
blunder i was about to take and walk
into this
okay let's be careful
so there's a nice wall
i want to time okay
so lockheed predicted correctly
appreciate the
the bits
foreshadowing w bits what about on
person on move 31 did it work
oh i didn't even consider that
i was completely blind to that i just
saw the tension i feel i have a pawn on
g4
good points i should have played that
it's like it should have been the only
legal move
oh no my
croissant yeah it just it solves all my
issues and then i could play this move
and
control the file
i mean the funny line i
i saw i was expecting this
and then the calculation was this this
this this
and if the pawn were on c3 here i'd be
in some trouble but with the pawn no
longer on c3 i would have this move
and then
nice pawns
okay i still won
good game though
okay so because i want a game i'm just
working the next game
unless i play someone 2400 plus
also it's time to boil some more water
make some more tea
still going for a quaid variation
aerocon okay i'll play d3
thank you stephen gray
gifting five
despite my lack of ability to on passant
what is this position
i should take one of these things
oh yeah the water is boiling so i know
the audio's a bit scuffed but
it'll go back to normal momentarily
because the kettle is right next to my
setup
i berserked ah i have to move quicker
i've been so confused by the tension
[Music]
i have to move a lot quicker
pawn takes i take here
we'll trade down a bit
now f3
i like the position now
happy pieces
bishop's attacked
and now i'm threatening to take because
the knights pinned
also threatening to take here
okay
that was nice
water's boiled
for some
real comfort tea because i'm talking a
lot
and my throat needs comfort
act tournament
164
okay
thanks again lockheed
for the w bits
see how many w's i can get this
tournament
okay this time i'll remember that i've
deserved oh opponent back
how does the gambit go again i don't
think box going into it though
also this position already looks very
nice
so now here i can take maybe
but maybe not maybe i take with bishop
first
and then take hit the queen at the
bishop
bishop c5 i just play king h1
okay pawns are meant to be pushed
and the center is meant to be controlled
i'd like to go for this move
b6 and then this move
or
this move okay
oh
opponents are missing mate
typical mating patterns
okay got another w
[Music]
a play against a bird
what's missouri i'll play e6
play something a bit more positional
this pawn might be hanging
although maybe not
okay increasing a lot of tension
i can't take the pawn but maybe i'm
threatening this move
oh i don't think it works so
feels close to working
like when d3
i might as well trade going for the fork
really invading white's territory here
h4 is also looming
yeah knight f3 kind of solves things
play this move
idea of bishop to come in
knight d4 i play h4 g4 rook g3
imposition looks really really nice
idea this and this
it takes i take
if this i can play this or this
probably this
arguing this this this this this
oh does that not work
i mean this should be good enough
here we go
if i'm not going for the discovery i'm
just going for the
domination of white soul
our pieces are so happy
i'll take a thing
i'm meeting
that's close to mate
also close to flagging i should move
quicker
it's confusing because there's so many
different good looking moves
just have to stay focused
knight c4
i'm not guaranteed to win this
okay now i'm guaranteed to win this
okay
oh that took work
i miss made in one really
i mean it looked so so good
rook g1 king e2
that's probably a quicker way to
yeah that's force mate
rook g1 he too
[Music]
i took the pawn the pawn was looking so
delicious
but this this
this would have been a nice me too good
night eric
my sleep medicine is kicking in
i'll catch more later and i'll watch the
replay
thanks for the games oh thanks for all
the bits even gray
[Music]
wait am i your sleep medicine or maybe
you have other types of sleep medicine
i'll enjoy your sleep
maybe i'll still address you even if
you're not here because you'll be
watching the replays in the future
i'll still i'll still be going for a
quaint gambit too at some point
this king's gambit line
okay so just to show the mate if king
here
it's made in two after this is this
and then if king here it's made in three
after this this this
this and this
so
what to do
still managed to win back the tournament
getting back on my berserking streak
hey top hundred
let's go
i guess i jumped a lot of places there
top 80
73 points 78th place
i've accomplished my bucket list item
i'm still going for a
quaid again
hmm
[Music]
okay
i play this as black
i don't usually play this as white
d4
i'll admit i don't know too much theory
your streams definitely don't put me to
sleep oh
they do for some people as far as i'm
aware
if anyone has been put to sleep by this
stream
make yourself known in chat
i wonder if anyone's like been active in
chat
while
asleep
like instead of sleepwalking like people
sleep sleep chat
other thing
also what is this pawn doing in my face
pawns offended
i'll play g4
very strange position here this bishop's
not defended so
maybe it could be exploited
best tea for sleep
oh uh yogi caramel bedtime
recommended by tim ferriss
or there's uh there's one with uh kava
too
i think also from yogi
oh that's a tricky move
oh i can take this though
very confusing position
[Music]
if g6 i might have to play queen b1
like the only safe square for the queen
or i could sack my queen
uh let's do this
i might be in some trouble here
take
the knight's going to be misplaced
and this knight is going to be the
opposite of misplaced
i think this and maybe this
um
it looks scary for that but this is not
clear
f6 could move
[Music]
now i'm threading the pork
in plus fork
wait the bishop was hanging i didn't
take the bishop
so much regrets at least my knight's
getting in
a very tricky position
bishop f4 expected
427
14 seconds
oh no my pawn
oh no my other pawn
not what i wanted i'm down three pawns
i'm down three pawns
i have an active king
and then octopus knight
i'll play this move
okay it's getting interesting
i have no time
mmm
i feel bad
there is a potential mating idea
um instead of rook b2 i should have
played rook b1
and if a4 then rook h1 is made
but because i played rook b2 i can't
play rogue h2 because
bishop takes h2
unless i missed something earlier
it was hard to force the king to take h6
with my nine e6
okay
yeah it's tough losing increments
liked my position at some point
i guess before queens were traded around
here
and 95 was maybe over ambitious
maybe should have played this
or this
yeah did i miss me
real quick
oh
oh yeah i missed the free bishop
my one chance to to win the game
or this moment what's this moment
rook takes e3
oh and knight g5 i should have fine
should have found that
okay back to tournaments
so no berserking next game
raiding is taking a small hit
that's kind of the nature of these
tournaments
so what do i need to do
to get to top 10 i just need to pass a
hundred points
okay playing a black mustang
um
going for
more of a reverse grand prix
opponent just doing their thing
kind of a king's indian attack setup
white wants to play this
queen e7 is a move
a4 is actually a move too
[Music]
maybe i'll play a4
idea if takes i check
a kind of weird prophylactic move
okay now we're getting reverse king's
gambit vibes
play d5
maybe this first
knight e4 then d5
oh but then i have to take with rook
g4 will come
it's interesting
i mean g4 is really the expected move
here
c4
also interesting
play 97
was the pawn
okay now i can choose which pawn to take
i think i want to take that
f pawn
[Music]
now both d pawns are hanging knight e4
expected
the rook back on f8
this pawn is still defended by the
tactic
white could defend with knight c3
okay now i just want to be
solid and happy
mr multi singularity saw my instagram
oh yeah i have some
some various kangaroo pictures
on
instagram
tennis with levy was good we played on
two separate occasions
played a couple days ago
late this morning
levy improved a lot since like the
like the first day we played
i was saying this earlier but he
he gained a few hundred elo just by
fixing some
simple things
because he's only been playing for
i think maybe a few weeks or a few
months
the queen here's a move
27
[Music]
i think i can get away with this
the rook in
also thank you off the schneed summing
for 20 months
i did record a bit of the tennis today
that i might uh might end up putting
together a highlights reel
if people want to see tennis content
i do have
probably a handful of videos
use a new youtube command
my pawn
ah i had to keep my rook defending the
pawn
okay i'll play b5 here
defending attacking
[Music]
so now i'm down upon
i have to treat the blunder as a gambit
b4 is a move
bishop here bishop here
etc etc
[Music]
actually don't mind the position extra
pawn for white isn't too meaningful
and my pieces are happy
have a small time advantage
okay this pawn's a bit ten a bit tender
but if uh
if takes i have rook here a3 and then c5
let's start with king h8
get the queen to a safer place i might
be losing this pawn
because now c5 is probably not happening
although okay if takes i can take and
then win b2 in the end
and then maybe loose e6 on the end
i don't know what's happening here
i just have to play quickly
it should be for coming
still some nagging pressure against f2
as well
hard to exploit though
i'll play with p8
this is not going to be a 24 hour stream
at the very most maybe 21 hours
um more likely
i had to guess probably like six to
eight hours
but we'll see
okay if i take
taking is actually kind of logical
and i want to keep winning chances alive
maybe rook a4
but then the knight comes in
[Music]
to do rook b6
i just want to target this pawn
okay got the focus here
we put the bishop in
f2 is still a target
you trade bishops okay
get some better palm structure
i have the idea to triple up
also threatening to win this pawn
yeah white's under a lot of pressure
here
might as well take
if this i can take
okay
looking very good now oh still not over
though
good move
did this move
and this move
fun is hard to defend
isn't meaning
better be meaning
meaning
i don't see mates
like this
okay i mean i'm playing for a win up a
pawn
i think i want to put the bishop here
i just have to gain time i also want to
trade off
bishop for night
hmm
let's go eric
i'm trying i'm trying i'm trying
there we go let's go night's stuck
now it should be an easy man
i'll walk around with the king
that's the dominance of the bishop over
the night now it looks wrong
okay persistence pays off don't flag
i'm not flagging don't worry unless
you're talking to my opponents
but
yeah now it's a
simple kingpin ending
okay a nice little end game lesson there
i have to be patient
that table base one two three four five
six seven no
um
objectively it might be drawn
but i just have to be patient and i'll
wait for the
opportunity
let's go
thank you lockheed thank you jimster
yeah where's tagi
maybe tagi will be
here eventually
i have to keep summoning him
thank you wretched talon subbing for
half a year
also thank you adrian kenobi
and jay cormack extending their sub
through november
okay so i won a game so i'm just working
this time
i'll try and redeem the budapest
okay three things to take in queen h4
um
it's a playable move
okay opponent kind of knows what they're
doing
i have some idea what i'm doing too
[Music]
i'm just getting my knights in decent
position
looks like a really risky move
hard to punish
i though to play this move
smile
oh thanks for the smile music by jim
i'll try and give people more reasons to
smile here
i mean it's a happy position
[Music]
knight b3 incoming
maybe some knight
do i go for that
the bishop here first
i might want to take and then play
knight d4
the knights are smiling
i'm allowing knight d5 but i'm
reinforcing d4
if ever knight d5 then there's a
prospect of b5
might also just want to go for rook bab5
it takes ooh okay let's play this first
getting off the diagonal
getting ready to take
a lot of attacking potential here
only one's knight f6
i'll give them what they want
i think there's a lot of compensation
[Music]
it's getting spicy though
ec3
the c3 is definitely the main idea
i'm just trying to calculate
yeah something like c like takes c3
takes knight a5
and now c2
a2 is forced only legal move
and now
[Music]
i assume i just take the rook
i under promote tonight
ah let's take the rook
oh
i guess it's not over i'll put knight
though
i think
could have taken the queen
let's make luft
it still takes work
time is
not super comfortable
[Music]
am i meeting i don't know if i'm mating
though
it feels feels close
i made
this move
that's not what i wanted
no
what's going on though
oh
oh that went downhill so quickly oh such
a confusing position
where is my win
i feel like this is a type of position
like in a puzzle book
was knight c1 force mates but what
points
knights are so confusing
[Music]
because the rook is hanging
and there's prospect upon promoting
so
what i initially wanted to do
[Music]
was play queen c
queen f1 here
but i saw like takes takes maybe not so
clear
i'm still not seeing the win
i'm sure there's a win somewhere maybe
this is a
another option
[Music]
oh maybe just rook g8
because then if this i take the pawn
let's move rick g8
rook g8 doesn't work to do to queen f3
i have to play this
wait rook d8 is winning what do i play
i did play rook t8
and now only winning move
is knight c1 first
and then this so i don't give white the
opportunity to sack
that's actually really crazy and if this
white makes two queens
but because i'm controlling d3 there's
no checks
i'm threatening made in two
and if king b1
check here
oh i win the queen in the end that's
crazy so i'm not mating
but i win the queen
i'm up at night
oh that's hard to see
what a game
[Music]
gg
also yeah in this position white could
take this queen first
and then take here and i lose both my
queens
oh no my queens
i could have lost both queens
[Music]
hey it's thirsty monster appreciate the
raid
if you're just joining
i lost this
[Music]
i could have lost a lot more easily
though
after it takes
i was thinking about under promoting to
a knight
which is not called for
oh queen b5 would have been simpler
okay anyway for those just joining
i'm playing the autumn marathon
um
it's been a tough tournament
it's a long term man 24 hour tournament
uh
i am
approaching the two and a half hour mark
i've been playing a lot of kings gambit
also not working in this game
caro con time
i'll play the line that i recommend in
my never mind
i was gonna play the two nights attack
but
hey d6 is uh
does this move
if takes there's a funny line
i was really hoping for takes and then
here and then oh no my queen and then
mate
but it's not happening
okay so we have some
interesting position
no trades yet
yeah it is kind of like a caro con down
a tempo
debating whether to play g4
queen d3 but then bishop g6
i think i'll play g4
nice aggressive move queen e2
reinforce the pawn
knight d6 ideas
expecting this move
or that move
okay so i have the bishop here
question from
reim swara
i usually play the sicilian
uh in serious tournament chess yes
but online
i usually play staffer gambit
or other gambits of sullivan gambit etc
but sicilian is one of my more like
serious openings for black
i'll go for g5
maybe get a rook in
[Music]
oh beat me to it
the thing about black's position the
king really doesn't have a safe place to
go
if castling then i'm just cutting
through the dark squares
oh
okay idea knight c4
there's a really cool move i want to
play here
i'm not sure if it works but it looks
really cool
um probably doesn't work i was thinking
d5 obstruct the queen from
covering e5 and then go for this
but then there's still bishop d6
for example here it takes here and then
here
also prospect of taking
good move knight b6
go for this move
solid hitting the knight
have you played sullivan yet
i did one game it was declined
it was a nice game it was uh
maybe about an hour ago
i would play more of sullivan
i should get at least one sullivan
accepted
okay
what to do
the knight's no longer pinned
didn't move back
what just happened
so that could repeat
knight p6
then maybe i'll play f4
always repeat twice but never three
times
hey it's samsonite yo yo always enjoy
watching these tournaments welcome back
subbing for 38 months
good to see you
yeah it's officially after midnight my
time
so
it's saturday in st louis
happy weekend
opponents taking time here
and the dream is to do this and win the
queen
i guess this and then this
ooh
[Music]
and now i can't play that immediately
because takes
like we have three
is defending the queen defending the
pawn
going for knight c4
i'm dreaming of the mating ideas
against uh
black's
queen side
like the main idea is to play this and
then eventually knight b6 mate
but that would require deflecting the
queen
i still have my gamut notepad my
girlfriend dana says hi
oh hi to dana
also hi to rappy6 thanks for subbing
i played 150 points above my normal
rating be proud please smile
uh okay i'll smile just for you
and for this position
position is looking fun
i'm gonna play king c2
preparing a4 to trap the queen
um
okay now this square is available
time situation is very very good
i'll put the rook back on
no not on d2
that's a mouse slip
it's not a bad move though
i was considering this to
discourage b5
and black has to make every move within
two seconds basically
okay the rook is coming in
oh
it's made into
[Music]
one
or i went on time so if this uh queen c6
was made
be a cool mate
how's the queen's pinned and the
bishops do work
there's a name for this mate
maybe like the bowdoin
this is some variation of the building
mate
thank you lockheed for more w bits
okay so i won a game
[Music]
ah still not
still outside the top hundred
i did cross a top hundred so
it was an accomplished thing in my
bucket list but now i should say
i should write down like top 50.
okay i'm still going for the quaid
variation
f4 would be probably one of the worst
moves there
i'll take and go for this line or this
line
so some queen g8 scandi
i can go for this
already some pressure on black
i take i'll probably take some rookie
one
have the bishop hair
i'm gonna try and keep things simple
also have to keep moving quickly too
[Music]
wow
a fancy move
if takes her as takes so
i want to take and provoke the double
pawns
also applying pressure here
i take
i think that quite works
let's play this move and
i have i had bishop e7
but now i no longer have this b7
oh no and my position is kind of
collapsing
[Music]
i have to take and go for this
i guess we'll trade queens
oh rook f8 doesn't work i was thinking
i'm waiting there but
oh not my proudest game
hey this move
i do this
12 seconds
let's go okay
opponent was trying to flag me
oh i really collapsed there it was such
a good position from the opening too i
just missed this move which would have
been completely winning
but
okay i got the
unexpected end game checkmates
it's hard to imagine mating in this
position
i've
this was moved 29 and i made it on move
33.
just had to create the net
okay
so i guess i'll keep berserking
top 90.
thank you lockheed some more w bits
stephen gray is still here
sort of still here sort of that one
deserves some bits
yeah i'm trying to counteract your sleep
medicine
he's berserk
okay uh let's play something really
solid i'll play my main stuff
qgd
play the 97 line
yeah it's very typical structure i don't
know if we're following like the right
move order but
again um
it's a trendy variation these
days i want to go for rook a6 and
[Music]
go for the double up
or the triple up
okay put the rook
here intruding along the a file
and target the pawn
the rook on a1
maybe maneuver the knight to f5
was white trying to do rook a2
because takes in rook a2 is playable
but it's not pleasant for white
like win the pawn
okay the invasion has
has worked nicely
knight b3 is now a threat
maybe queen c3
let's offer the trade
go after this pawn now
i still want to do this maneuver
i'm dreaming of porking
easier said than done
gotta manage time to
check
does that work probably not
okay going in for the kill
past pawns must be pushed
now have an octopus knight
oh not
f1
only legal move okay that was a nice
game
i was the strongest player i've played
so far this tournament
i should have uh uh some more bucket
list items i beat an i
am and then be the gm
okay so still a lot of
bucket list items
to achieve
but we're going back thank you lockheed
thank you itchy 80
subbing for 14 months
and tiny dinky daffy saying play the
knight d7 line
oh the knight d7 is what i just played i
guess
okay please berserk back
opponent's not because working
gotta play quickly and
try and play solidly
international master beats international
master
yeah it's uh international master
reception
this is still prep actually it's like
the main main line
so the idea is to play this move
i don't think i've seen bishop f5 before
but it shouldn't change much
maybe it changes things a little bit b5
rookie 4 i'll play this move
trying to create some mating ideas
yeah so i want to play h5 soon
h5 queen g4 and h4 is a plan
and take and play a5
sometimes a typical way to meet the
minority attack is to
with outside passer
i should play queen g4
thinking i need to defend the pawn
although okay maybe bishop b4 and i can
go after this pawn
preventing knight c3 and rook b5
i'm kind of switching gears and going
for more
positional play
knight f4 is coming
it takes its meeting not quite mating
but winning
also preparing g5 maybe
tricky position though
i think i want to play this next
still ideas of this
could end up repeating
oh no not g5 i'll play this move
losing a pawn but
oh no not losing a pawn because a
knight needs some babysitting
i think i want to play this
i might bail out for a draw
although maybe i can like just go for
the kill too
a4 ideas
yeah i might be billing out here
we'll see how much risk i want to take
g3
f4 might be coming
oh i didn't see that
i'm in trouble now
[Music]
oh no
have this move
defending things kind of
oh this is terrifying
am i losing
that's crazy if it's losing
after this and this
wow and white finds it too that's really
crazy
it's just losing
[Music]
that's so sad
[Music]
this there's takes
uh what's my best hope
play this and keep the queen
and pray for some perpetual
or some stalemates
not giving up just yet
and now it's
pretty much time to give up
unfortunately
still some still made ideas but not
quite
okay
what to do oh i should have played one
more move hoping for queen f6
well i played really well in that game
um
yeah i kind of just got ground down
i just defended the queen side
i was feeling optimistic after queen g4
but
apparently that was a terrible blunder
if i take and probably rook 8 it's still
playable
[Music]
i haven't seen ip7
i didn't see 96 like this key
i thought we were gonna go into this and
maybe it would be a draw
anyway back to tournament
nice
oh goodnight lockheed
thanks for the bits
and chest tricks okay not because
working if i lose i don't berserk until
i win and then i
go back to berserking wait what what do
i do now
chat do i berserker do i not berserk
tell me what to do
people are just saying nice
someone says no
someone else says yes
ah it's too late okay i guess i'm not
berserking
okay let's
defeat this poor soul
it's nice having an early time advantage
and increment for once
okay pawns are happy
i want to play this and this wow
blocks making my life easier
running two different mates in one
these pieces don't really help defend
the king
[Music]
this pawn is trying to help
okay that was pleasant
okay i'll go back to berserking
this next game
oh go for a goddess
which i've okay i can't play here
this is more uh
more typical kind of scandy structure
i don't mind this
maybe it's a little bit passive
good of his pieces to block his other
pieces for you
that's true yeah
ah you're still awake
um
i wish my opponents would do that more
often
okay i want to play this in castle queen
side and then go for the
monster attack
c4 might be coming the c4 there's knight
f4
in this move
uh let's start with this move
now there's no time for hesitation
so this position really just comes down
to who can attack more quickly
going for g4
and b5 might be coming b5 i probably
take
white's trying to scare me
i'm also trying to scare white
knight moves i win the
pawn h5 opens i might just be mating
wow what is this
aches
oh my queen
wow well played
it's still interesting though
i'm treating this as a gambit
i'm losing more material though oh it's
so bad
i have this move i guess
trying to defend everything
that's a really uncomfortable position
this pawn's annoying
[Music]
oh white found a nice tactic
and now i'm suffering
[Music]
[Music]
i blundered a rook there but white
didn't punish me
i still have all my minor pieces
unfortunately i'm lacking
i'm lacking a lot of things
oh no
stop hurting me
stop it
this is really sad the position was so
good earlier
there is potential stalemates
i'm hoping for f4
not having much luck here
okay oh that was rough
that's a nice position though too
[Music]
ah so b5 was really clever
i just didn't have any sense of danger
there
i thought white was just kind of going
nuts
so in hindsight
maybe queen d6 is a the way to go
to set up the battery
that should be good for black but
that's maybe really unclear but yeah
queen d6 would be a nice uh
nice option
okay
no berserking
63rd place
i haven't lost two games in a row
only games i've lost i deserved
given the the thing i'm doing
i think like once i get to top
let's say top 30 i just stopped is
working entirely
hey it's an ortho snot maybe
no it's not an ortho shop
ortho shop is on my bucket list
okay we'll have a marathi vine vs
hedgehog
and this is an opening i usually like to
go for in
slow classical chess very positional
debating this in this
i'll play bishop b3
oh botezz gambit okay i did blunder a
queen
otez gambit accomplished
okay
opponent wants to go for this
one also wants a draw which
i don't really want
and to understand this position
question where my knight wants to go
there's g4 here
i think i'll start with this and discard
this and this
then i can
discourage black's knights from
achieving their dream squares
black wants to play f5 the problem is i
can just take and it takes there's a
fork
i forgot to take my tea bag out it's
been brewing for at least 40 minutes
okay g5
this move looks really enticing
this black has to oh black's gonna play
this
but now f5 is not possible
it's going to be a really close position
offer the trade
g4 probably just wasn't good
it's still playable
i want to play this in h4
unboxing together really good nights
on e5
interesting
might as well take
objectively i'm
slightly worse here probably
but there's room to play for something
this could be a long game
[Music]
one of these grinding
and game positions
the first question is what is my plan i
want to be here
my king
okay my king wants to be towards the
center
the objective would be to take over the
c file but it's not easy to do
could throw an h4
i was scared of black playing h5 which
might still be a move
and now at least i dictate the
like when the tension is released
and if it takes i
well that i can take here
wait a minute
might be better to leave the tension
oh
okay let's take and take
the knight's going to be forced back to
f7
the thing is it's hard to make progress
from here
i'm threading this uh e5 and bishop g6
um
the a4 maybe b3
opponents still offering a draw
yeah this looks pretty josh
going to play on
position is solid enough
we trade rooks yeah my king isn't quick
enough
we trade rooks this way and my king is
probably quick enough
oh
okay
now we'll see if i'm actually right with
this
so here here here here
a5 is probably the best tribe and now i
this move
the b6 i take and
win the pawn
a black's in trouble here now
it might still be holdable but
so now the plan would be to walk around
and win d6
it's pretty much my only plan
the king's just too slow
[Music]
as this is like the worst square for the
king on the board
any other square
man thumbs up
oh wait no king b6 is not legal
why was i thinking this and then this
oh no
[Music]
i'm so broken now
what did i just do i had to play this
and then
there's a b5 i'm losing to tempe with
this
no
okay still trying to play for a win
that's so sad though
do i play for a win and risk losing
you're here here
i'll repeat once
i'm playing for a win
yolo
it's really risky
young children close your eyes
i actually don't know what's happening
now it's interesting
it might be losing for me but it might
not be
make all three results possible
i think it's winning
the black's gonna be in zuma's long
eventually
the king's tie down to the pawn
running this
and it's hard to believe
i'm still winning this
despite
losing those two tempe
yeah takes takes and zugzwang
okay persistence pays off
a good thing i didn't berserk this game
really needed the increment too
this bishop was so sad for so long
okay good game to ted
that's a long game
okay
64th place
i go back to berserking i think i do
because in an arena tournament
his opponents beat me every single time
winner winner chicken dinner
chicken dinner
mmm chicken dinner
okay let's try and not lose to this
opponent
stop is working
c3 okay i'll take and play this
oh
cd4
i'll admit i am out of theory
concerning queen d7
trying to evaluate this knight
knight jump
oh there's a funny line e5
maybe just queen c8
also thinking here here and then a6
95 takes takes knight here
let's try that queen feels better on d7
it's just about dealing with this idea
like hopefully i'm not walking into
anything too nasty
before
[Music]
bishop d6 now
ah but then takes and i lose b7
play this move
a3 i can maintain the pin
now i kind of want to play this move
it's going all in
preventing light from castling
if i take
all the time or take twice
still kind of like this better though
down a minute i like the position
[Music]
sometimes you have to invest time to
get a likable position
okay so now it wants a castle
[Music]
g5 comes to mind
now g4
i'm really trying to play aggressively
here
maybe rook g8
so i'm getting ready to
go for the kingside attack
wow g4 okay maybe takes and
just move back
i'm not sure if white wants a castle
here
e4 i kind of forgot about
[Music]
white wants to castle harold and kumar
wanted white castle
uh
i don't know who harold and kumar are
i know what white castle is
white castle should sponsor this move
i see five is coming i gotta move
quicker
f6
27
[Music]
some rook c8
happy to see that trade
i have h5
i'm making things spicy here
i have the increments which is nice
i'll put the knight here
oh no
i'm just losing now i have this move
it's really bad though
that's actually really bad
did this move
[Music]
maybe
i'm like playing quickly
maybe missing some opportunities it's
still really bad
let's take
and where does my night go
oh this position is really unpleasant
or this and pray
it's not looking good
hoping for a miracle
hey it's white castle
i have this move that's a soft queen h5
still alive somehow
what do i do
it's completely losing
it's a fancy move
oh no
don't hurt me
i resigned okay
oh that was rough
good game though
poland played well
kind of got outplayed there
slightly off be line in the london
[Music]
i felt like i had so much pressure here
wow it's just better so g5 is probably
oh it's still better here
wait
that just works the whole game
i guess white defended well
i really thought i had some nice
pressure there but
well going forward
it just got worse and worse
each takes g4 is stronger
it's an interesting line maybe i should
look into
some knight a5
interesting
and if queen a4
bishop d7
uh
okay
awesome learned
okay what to do
dope is working
can i drop a nugget of end game wisdom
the first thing that comes to mind
uh
[Music]
king power use your king as an act of
peace
i know in the opening middle game you
protect your king but in the end game
king activity can be really really
important
okay i'm still going for this quaid
variation
hey it's the first king's gamut accepted
[Music]
uh
is this possible i don't think it's
possible we need a g5
also what is this move
i fall into some trap
i probably did
okay bong cloud
long cloud kings gambit
this looks playable actually
i don't think i mind this
maybe i do
bishop f5 i have queen b5
position looks good
apart from the fact my king's on e2
that's the thing with king's gambit
theory i don't really know
like these tricky sidelines
i know what free pawns taste like
although i don't want to overeat
because takes takes takes there's
ruxiates
looks kind of scary
like g4
[Music]
what to do here
maybe 92
that's probably not a great move but
it's a legal move
yeah so we're getting some version of
this which
okay i'm eating a lot of pawns
i'm feeling a little bit full
i'm up three pawns
okay lock's gonna take and probably win
back at least two of them
and then have compensation
oh box how you think rook takes c3
but then i have knight takes e4 that's a
bit messy
yeah if i took back there's a fork
okay
we have some weird position
[Music]
e2's hanging
[Music]
controlling the center
box just calmly castles
we'll play h3
going for g4 bishop g2
[Music]
it looks a little bit slow but
i didn't see what else to do
okay things are getting weird
this i have this
and then the queen's attacked
i'm looking at this uh i take the bishop
i lose her rook i win the knight
kind of forgot about that move
like queen f3
queen b2 probably coming
[Music]
so rook b1 doesn't work
i mean b3 doesn't work
probably rook d1
just gotta hold on for dear life
ah d4 is hanging too
i really gotta hang on for dear life
this is not a good position
there's this move maybe
bishop g2
and still queen d4 is coming
i think i start with this and then pray
wow how does this move
opponent just wants to maybe
should probably move the queen
between d3 runs into bishop c4
[Music]
i have this move
now the move i want to play though
but maybe i have to
a box playing a game so far
just trying to roll with the punches
the problem with this it leaves my
nightlist offended
oh no
i have this
i'll try this
so if takes i can take the bishop
or the other bishop i don't know
every move feels like i'm getting
punched in the face
it's not a good feeling
like this
at least i have increment i should be
grateful
[Music]
maybe i can get an end game down two
pawns i think that's the best hope
oh no
knight d3 is coming of this move
i also have two seconds left
ah i got tricked
okay
i'll try and hold on
not getting mated immediately
i am down a queen for a rook
yeah black played a really nice game
king a1
oh no
my king
black hasn't even used the rook yet
slightly concerning
the king activity this is the endgame
nugget from earlier
use your king as a weapon
this is kind of unfortunate though
seeing you play these king gambits
brings me joy i believe when they play
the early bishop e7 that h4 is the move
having to bomb cloud there isn't the end
but it does make developing and getting
the attack started harder
okay that's it's a good lesson to learn
wait so
i appreciate you staying awake to teach
me
the king's gambit secrets
oh h4
h4 is a it's a hard move to
consider i guess i should have seen this
idea
although stockfish doesn't like h4
but maybe
wait what do masters play
bishop c4 oh i like bishop c4
ring f1 square
oh thank you julian to japper
says test donation please ignore
okay well sorry for not ignoring that
ah that's my first two losses in a row
okay let's try and come back strong
thank you franchise
clubbing for 10 months
it's gonna be tough to climb
other people are climbing around me
okay the more kings gambits i play the
stronger i get in the king's gambit
already liking this opening
[Music]
it's reminiscent of grand prix
um
i think this works actually
yeah opening trap this only works for
the pawns on f4
because normally uh there'd be queen g5
after it takes here queen g5 but i take
back with check
that's crucial to have the work on f1
and pawn and f4
here we go and i'll
win the bishop
okay
this is what i need after the previous
game
[Music]
just some feel good kings gabbits
race yourself for forks
they're about to come
okay
that was pleasant eleven move win with
the king's gambit let's go
very few accepted lines tonight yeah
people are scared if people just see you
and are like no way
not accepting any rows and gambits
that's possible
[Music]
okay so i beat this player earlier
and we played a lot of times on the
chest
okay pretty classic uh close the ceiling
position
i had a similar type of attack earlier
this time i take on croissant
use some queen h5
i honestly didn't see my rook was
hanging
[Music]
h5 or queen d1 is tempting now
[Music]
um
i'll play this so
[Music]
objectively i'm worse here but there's
still chances to fight
with neither bishop or maybe just queen
d1
yeah the structure is really nice now
just keep losing material though
i want to play rook h2
h6 is now under fire
and eventually i want to sack somewhere
somehow some way
or just went on time
i was calculating knight g7 in the sign
that's interesting
save the bishop
it's still my g7 i think
because of takes i take and win the
queen
oh i might lose my queen ah
it's not so bad though
my bishop before
i could move
i'm in some pawns
um
bye
let's go okay
ah
the thing is if i flag i lose because
the knight is enough mating material
when i have pawns
wow
okay so i didn't fall below 2600 let's
go nice
it's stressful
i should charge my watch my watch is
about to die but
maybe after
like half hour of charging
i'll put the heart rate monitor on
also back to berserking
also staffer gambit time
maybe
hopefully please
make things spicy
come on eat my spicy pond
let's eat
spicy food
you know you want to
it tastes like sriracha
there's still a chance
okay
i feel sad now
but sometimes when you're sad you want
to do things that make you happy
like g5 g4
whoa
what is white doing white's doing the
same thing i'm doing
okay
looks playable
kind of
symmetrical
i want to bring the knight here
the queen here
maybe c5 at some point
just to prevent d4
d4 is not really a threat
but maybe i do start the maneuver
some b5 ideas as well
i just accidentally defended the pawn
um
pix
knight here
i haven't had a pawn cube yet i might be
getting a pawn cube soon
got my pawn tetris piece
also there's potential for quadruple
pawns
hey it's a pawn cube
pawn cube where's my pawn cube
on cube
okay
that was a very short-lived cube
okay now going for the kingside play
oh thank you royejo
welcome back appreciate the bits
e5 i will take
i legally castle i think i can
i think i will
but maybe start with this move
eyeing the square
hey it's pinky yo
get the raiden
welcome welcome shout out to binky yo
361 if you're just joining
i'm playing the autumn marathon
playing spicy food let's eat
i beserk this game so i have no
increment
uh so i'm trying to go for some quick
meet
start with this
and then i'll castle
[Music]
assuming white
oh now i can't really castle i play this
move no i can't
okay let's play this and this
no castling for me
again the end game tip from earlier use
your king as a weapon
[Music]
the pawn was hanging but it looked risky
to take
yeah these end games usually come down
to which player can best optimize your
king and rook
uh take and win the pawn
this should be winning now
[Music]
and there's rook f6
it's going to turn into a pawn race
ooh
i'll play b4
and go after the b3 pawn
setting up a small trick
actually isn't so simple to win
[Music]
okay now it's simple to win
yeah king c1 may have been
like objectively drawn
yeah there should be plenty of time
now the way to win this is to gradually
walk up with the king and rook and pawns
kind of use the pawns as a shield from
the checks
there we go
okay that's nice
a slightly spicy game
back to tournament
hey top 50 okay top 50 accomplished and
pawn cube accomplished
so here's my bucket list
pawn cube top 50
i kind of bond clouded earlier but
not a true bond cloud
okay
ooh danish gambit or center game
let's go
let's go
this evening gray's still here
okay playing
i don't know what this is
but it's something
i want to push my a pawn
or maybe push my b-pawn
[Music]
and then castle at some point
some idea to bring the bishop in
been fighting it for a while but the
eyes are heavy
oh
if your eyes are heavy you might have to
lift some more
[Music]
hey it's eight counts
oh it counts maybe i'll go for a danish
gambit because i didn't get a true
danish the other
day i still owe you one
i thought that this game might go into a
danish
appreciate the 20 dollars
lift eyelids get swole yeah
there are a lot of things you can lift
to get swole
[Music]
eyelids rooks
arms
i might actually want a rook lift here
target b2
[Music]
get swole
seems like a nice life plan
um
bishop c3 is coming i'll play this move
some idea knight f5
now i just don't know what's happening
[Music]
i kind of miss that
though maybe i can take
it's confusing now
i have to play that
okay so the light's undefended
prospect of this
a4 actually looks really nice
the takes and possibility of this
still play for also play this
in the process of getting swole
that's a move
c7 is undefended
one wants to fork me
i still probably want to play for
bishop c3 is coming
what
was that move that forced my things but
i took it and
i just won a knight
not sure what my opponent overlooks
there
wow
white resigns white still could have
tried to dirty fog me
also goodnight to josh thanks for being
here
i appreciate you being
present
shout out to josh
i hope your night is better than
this night
this could have been a really good fork
if my bishop weren't here
okay
hey four in a row when it comes to forks
it is better to give than receive
i mean that last fork i was very happy
to receive
okay this is working again
e4 again
to my
sicilian prep
a fork was guarded by a bishop
otherwise known as a pork
that's a nice word
a bork it's like an ingredient for
borsch
also hello to cryberry carly thanks for
raiding i appreciate that
um
shout out to crybaby carly
if you're just joining it's been a long
stream
i'm trying to stay
somewhat energized and awake
i'm playing the
other marathon this is a 20
four hour tournament
i did late join
less than 18 hours left
also i berserk this game so i gotta move
quicker
maybe uh go for the quick attack
defend the pawn
i wanted to go for f5
looks risky though let's play this
thank you champ 1997
for 1977.
[Music]
oh i can't read
maybe f
let's go for f5
i've been playing the tournament for
almost four hours now
[Music]
uh let's save the thing
very tense position
and maybe now queen g3
just abandoning my pawns and going for
mate
okay threatening to take and then f6 and
mate
it's looking promising
it's still going to be a bit unclear
wow
[Music]
it's
i want to take
start with taking
it probably helped block more than helps
me
that f4 next
so it takes i i
i go for the fork
the rook bishop fork also guard g7
there's a line takes takes rook g7 and
then rook f8 rook f8 queen g7 mate
which i'm kind of hoping for
[Music]
guess that's a move
i have no time
[Music]
okay let's play this and
maybe should have taken
i don't think this is gonna end well
it might end well please take my thing
[Music]
no it's not ending well
ah my attack fizzled
the shizzle my fizzle
i was winning
i was winning i'm so tilted
all i needed were one two three four
five more moves
[Music]
i just or black just wonder their queen
ah it's so slow i wasn't expecting for
black to gift me everything there black
premo queen d3 which is kind of funny
well played though
there are some cool mating ideas
which didn't quite pan out
okay position should have been like
completely winning
around here
but what did i miss
oh 94 was good
this is the best line
okay so this is
x takes
so i played one of the best lines
but here yeah i should take it takes an
e6 and
rook comes in
when i took your eyes hoping for this
after which it's made in three
yeah i made i made a lot of blunders
this game
my opponent too
at least the graph is smiling
at my
sorrow okay back to tournaments
no berserking
trying to get back on track top 40
is something
lead school
lee eat
school stop for gaba time
it's nice when white starts thinking
here
never played this player before they
might not be familiar with the stafford
or maybe they were just deciding what to
do
okay white's playing one of the best
lines
i was actually looking at this on stream
yesterday
this bishop e3 like d4 bishop b3 line
bishop g4
i mean white's playing all the best
moves so far so
[Music]
uh there's not so much i can do
except hope and pray
you could look at that graph and think
you're made a lot of blunders but you
could also look at it and think you
built an overwhelming advantage twice
that's true yeah
that's a fair point
okay i have some vague memory of
actually studying this at some point
i think i played bishop before there's
some crazy like knight f3 idea
if the knight goes here and i have three
and
i remember studying this to try and
defeat hikarubot
unchest.com
i really want to take that
probably bishop e7
at least okay this was some success
because now the bishop's undefended
i am threatening to take
that's probably a good move
not a seven here
still threatening to take
love you dog
i love you too master
queen c2 okay going for this
play this
i'm just trying to get a playable
position here
so far white's avoided all my tricks and
funny lines
oh thank you tiny dinky daffy also thank
you chocolate boy getting merch can't
wait for my shirt
hey
oh no my queen shirt let's go
[Music]
i can't wait for my chocolate
so what am i doing in this position
[Music]
thinking v8
just have to chill
[Music]
a little bit concerned about my queen
and bishop getting trapped but
i don't see how white actually traps
things and now i have a plan
hmg5
trying to fight
good move
i want to play g3
contemplating the sack
it doesn't work but
the funny thing to contemplate
why has connect five
well i have a small blockade
also now maybe takes
the problem is i'm just losing at the
end of that line like takes takes takes
king h1 takes takes takes and an e6
and black is just lost
i have this move
this may be the way to go
something like that for resource
a difficult position though
i played this
because there's about five
i'm actually thinking about playing b5
here
okay let's go for this
you so i have a plan
[Music]
i really want to sack but it's not good
oh not the floor
metaphors also probably losing but
what to do
okay i'll give up the rook
at least i got rid of the monster pawns
only had to sack a rook for it
i have a monster pawn of my own
i want to play this in this
good move
white's played a good game what to do
again not resigning given what happened
that one previous game
[Music]
you never know
i could find
okay there's still some reason to play
on i have a pawn on g3
and now a pawn chain thing
i mean the whole
the hope is upon moves forward but
okay i resign
i wanted to mate but it was hard to do
yeah i think i just played the clean
game
if i play this player again i probably
don't play stafford
very clean
i guess e5
if i go into this line i play uh i could
play knight d5 actually
of d4
[Music]
basically remember there's a trap here
like d4
c5
is this a trap c4 in the knight b4
oh yeah this is actually a cool line
which is lesser explored
inviting c4 and knight b4 maybe i go for
that next time
okay
yeah vindictive has some idea of that
it's a bit more reliable than what i
went for
okay no berserking if you didn't know
that opponent is a genius of the game
oh yeah my point was kind of genius
based on their username
okay carol kahn time
i haven't had a two nights attack
a two night's attack time
just realizing i recommend bishop e2 in
my video
but this is also a playable line
idea to play g4 bishop g2
between g3
and queen g3 makes sense to prevent
bishop d6
and then like to go for castling
[Music]
already have potential for pawn swarming
so there's bishop e3 here
play that
tempo on the queen
i already have the bishop hair
i'm allowing this
the point is uh i'm threatening g5 i
think
removal of the guard
so if takes takes takes and g5 should be
fine for white
maybe this move
if this i can play this or this
i'd like to take but i'm not sure how
easy it is to exploit the
double pawns
i'll play this
i just looked at chat robert e says
someone should create eric rosen clones
uh
yeah i guess you would need my dna for
that right
oh there's a funny line
okay look at this move
i don't know if it works
it looks funny though
so oh no my pawn
but because the thing is aligned with
the thing
if queen a3 i have knight d5
green digs queen and then knight takes
e7
and then i regain the piece
and then my knight might get trapped
like this
or no i have this and uh rook d7 in the
end
that's kind of a cool line
black is aware of it
inserting e5 here
i like e5
it does block my bishop but it opens up
a bishop and knight
okay now my pawn is kind of actually
hanging
but then maybe i just play c3
and shun the queen from the rest of the
board
okay now i'd love to play this move
but maybe this what about eric rosen
franchises instead come on and pick up
some funny lines with your own oh my
queen merchant goose swan hats
someday i'll start a franchise
hey it's arcg3 what's up rg3
i think was also streaming this
tournament
appreciate the raid hope you have a good
time
i know it's uh
it's getting late for some of us
if you're just joining i am
trying to checkmate black
not so simple actually
looks like it should be simple
okay i think i'll start with this
forcing this and then this and then this
and then this
there's g5 bishop e4
yeah so calculation is um
rook d4 so threatening the classic
maiden two
g5 then i play this i broke g6 i just
take and it's mating
i think i have just enough manpower to
get the job done
oh arcg3 is gonna
stream as soon as he wakes up
oh maybe i can try and keep streaming
until
arcg3 wakes up
and then send a raid
not sure how much longer i'll last
just pass the four hour mark
thank you girardo mr
subbing for seven months
okay
black found a way to play on
[Music]
feels like it should still be
a somewhat straightforward win but maybe
not so clear
now i'm just preventing g5 entirely
also guarding b1
i have a slow plan of just lifting the
rook to h4
i'm getting swole
uh what's the threat
i play f3 just for safety
safety first defend the
bishop it's actually a really
interesting position
and it should be winning for white but
it takes work
okay i'll play king
h1
there's also this idea
which i think i'll go for
yeah i have too many ideas here
it's a free night
and now bishop f8
okay that was satisfying
check and
[Music]
for check and flag
okay
ah
oh no my rating i fell below 2600 how
many points have i lost this tournament
73 oh no
i was close to my peak earlier too
what's my most controversial opinion
um
[Music]
probably something about geese
i don't know i don't really form too
many opinions
that
that are subject to controversy goodwin
though i'd argue you had just enough
good ideas
opponent played a spirited defense
yeah it's very spirited
especially the final position very
spiritual
okay back to tournament
hey 42 the meaning of life also i passed
100 tournament points
oh traxler although i've usually been
playing the sicilian recently i got
myself into a must-win situation against
someone booked up on the traxler i
decided to go for the ultimate traxler
match up and won hey
okay working time good job addfost
i've added traxler to my bucket list
yeah berserking is not really great for
my rating
the h3 is a kramnik move i believe
i don't think kramnik combines it with
e4 maybe it's playable
i'm going to just set up the the classic
author attack
let's throw all the pieces of the king
side i hope it works
i'm going for this soon
i don't really
care about my
my pawn or my rook
i just care about mating
oh white's taking the bait
this is interesting now
uh oh my rook wasn't taken
okay well let's take with knight first
keep the bishop
berserking these people who are top 100
seems riskier than normal at the very
least they're having a good night
i'm having a better night
multiple better nights
okay now a good queen
i want to play this move
wait there's so many moves i want to
play
me this move
now you also play knight g4
or bishop h3
or combination of the moves
this is super super risky i'm throwing
made in one though
it looks kind of fun
[Music]
i'm just
neglecting everything
[Music]
bishop
bishop has served its purpose so
also writing this
uh
free night or free checkmate recheckmate
okay
well that was nice i paid off
17 moves
yeah we have a rare blue circle
[Music]
hold down alt for some reason
yeah the calculation
uh i was looking at bishop g4
this is that's confusing i think it's
winning though
king g1 keeps white alive
and then g5 and the game goes on
that's crazy
thank you archon theo gifting to osama
omr
and thank you good little doggy subbing
with prime
okay i'm gonna take a small break
uh bear with me
i'll put on some
let me pause
pause pause pause
watch the top game put on some
pentatonic
and i'll be back
momentarily
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
i'm back
so i'm on a two in a row streak
35th place
i think i start berserking more
that last game paid off
also i got some uh some rebel
kind of coffee maca thing
hey double berserk okay i'll leave on
pentatonic for one game
i'll play london i haven't played the
london so far
[Music]
94
which is bishop d3
[Music]
going for a nice positional advantage
5 takes 95
[Music]
i want to take that but it doesn't work
okay bishop g6 ideas
[Music]
bishop five
making f1
and now i think this works
we're gonna trade everything oh and then
i'm winning in the end game they have
the two outside passers
assuming takes here here i'm winning
i think
maybe i'll just win on time
[Music]
and this is another move
and then listen
[Music]
okay
hey okay so we're getting what i was
just calculating
i think it's winning
is b4 and
pawns go pushing
[Music]
also this is now zug's long these
squares are controlled
and it's a smiley face
okay that was nice
i'll turn the sound back to standard
got the best working points
back over 2600
thank you coil twitch bot
oh another game started
i had the tournament open in another tab
okay berserking continues
london time
so i had this uh line earlier queen b3 i
played that a5
there's a lesson learned
uh
i want to punish white
for leaving the queen there
hard to do
though i'll just play this
okay i want to play bishop f5
almost kind of felt like a blunder there
it was risky
i really can't get too long time
i'm losing a pawn
unless i'm not
it's not pleasant though
it's a good move
rook c7
a really difficult position
probably want to play h6 and induce the
trade
yeah this is looking bad if white finds
the right move
i found the right move
oh no i found the wrong moves
down two nights now
okay
uh let's resign
and move on
okay
yeah this is some kind of uh
like wellness drink
i kinda to beserk this player
but okay i'm going to follow the rule
uh
uh okay i'll be jerk
usually if i lose the game i don't
believe the next game but
my opponent berserks all happily
blizzard pack
let's just move
this position is very sus
i play this move
i'm just sagging a knight
let's see if i get some comp
that looks interesting
i'm down a piece but there is probably
some comp
that's a good move
i want to avoid the queen trade
i'm just down at night here
hey it's another raid
it's gm
hello to the grand master
i appreciate the rain
please keep streaming all night oh
we'll see
uh
as long as you stay awake i guess i can
keep streaming
this opponent has more holes in his
position than a slice of swiss cheese
cheese
my pawn
uh let's take and
[Music]
okay
so we both berserk so we uh neither of
us have increments
oh no
am i losing i might be losing
i have to try this
okay now it's okay i think
unless it's not okay
not great but it's playable still
going for the dirty flag
what else to do
foreign
okay i went on time
i feel slightly dirty i'm sure many
things were missed there but
got the job done i'll just work again
i think like statistically berserking is
probably
still better for the
like overall tournament performance
or for um accelerating the tournament
standing
even though it's riskier it um
it's worth the risk
okay yeah 92
just makes me happy
interesting
almost top 25 let's go let's go
i'm trying
i like the position here e5 is
potentially coming soon
and if takes takes i'll be threatening a
triple fork
92 is playable
oh queen h6 could be a move
uh
it was still a move
i think you should stop berserking when
you're on a streak
oh that's not a bad idea
but what if i'm on a berserking streak
what do i do then
[Music]
most of my streaks have been berserking
streaks actually
okay we're gonna trade into some
some type of end game i'll be up a pawn
though
assuming takes
or not
opponent wants to attack me
it will still trade queens
and losing a pawn back
i might be
[Music]
let's take this pawn you should also not
streak when you feel like berserking
do i berserk if i feel like streaking
okay wait let's focus
i have almost no time
am i getting mated no
uh checking rook c7
okay so this is like very equal
rook ending
which i'm gonna try and like play for a
win
because i have a slightly more active
king
first step is to
try and optimize everything
i might have to poke around for a bit
play b5 and
okay
two
[Music]
okay
i want to gradually advance the pawns
like king f4 soon
there we go
making progress
i'll be winning f3 can you two rookie
six check
my question isn't enough time
it should be
i have the two on one advantage
rook choose another idea here
yeah that kind of backfired for whites
here we go
[Music]
plenty of time
okay
barely enough time but enough time
nice
okay back to tournaments
2600 on the dots
120 tournament points
leader has
213 but it's paused
okay berserking again
i'm still waiting for my uh
the quack variation
i haven't played this opening in years
i learned this as a small child
i don't think i've ever seen g5 before
interesting move
uh let's take and go for f7
oh thank you streams on twitch
five gifted
appreciate that
my night's trapped what is this okay
let's take and
get some comp
uh check
a confusing position
here we go
oh it's still tricky
you have two maybe
keep the pawn defended
oh let's not uh
be careful here
here we go
let's go okay
so i'm on another berserking streak
hey top 25 let's go
what's on my bucket list i forgot about
my bucket list
traxler evan
okay
or to do anything against this move
i'll play a reverse grand prix
i like the fact white's playing quickly
and
about to
feel the pain of this attack
okay i was not caring about that pawn
i just want to lift a rook
my sniper bishop
and knight is rerouting
why just munching on my pawns what is
this
i go for this move
completely forgot there's this idea
yeah that's actually kind of unfortunate
i might be in some trouble here
the idea of taking
if takes i take take triple fork
okay just a standard fork
c5 i have queen
f7
looks to be okay
and the rook guards b7
i'm just in time to
get the rook back
i think
it's a little bit tricky though
[Music]
maybe this move
to give away d6
not what i wanted
you're threading this
very tricky
oh no
don't do it don't do it don't do it
i didn't do it why that knight c8 there
have to come in from behind
this takes full focus
try and walk the king up
took with the rook there was not a five
there
let's go okay
that's a staple consider
i'm sure there are things missed
in various moments
man
oh there's r7 yeah
or gauge seven could have been sad for
me
let's go
yeah i just had to keep enough time on
the clock
okay berserk streak continues
23rd place
slowly but surely
or quickly but surely
i'll take that
oh this is is this a goddess no
it's something though what is this
check
that was very well done
thank you steven gray appreciate that
i'm trying to stay awake and focus the
best i can do
uh this is a move
i think i'll play rook b1 though
defended
i feel like black is trying to play in
my style
just like playing super super
aggressively
which i don't mind
hopefully it backfires
i hear we're trading a lot
i'm up three pawns
f2 is defended
some b4 looks nice
bishop here i have this it takes i have
this
c5 is coming
this is also coming
some funny idea to play this move
no longer is so great because rook was
defended
okay
pawns are meant to be pushed
uh
i mean okay we'll trade queens
plenty of time here
okay let's go another berserk win
adriana how's it going
shout out to adriana
also hello to takiwahi
loving for three months in advance
appreciate that
if my opponent's not berserking i'm
gonna
have a difficult time here
[Music]
okay let's play aggressively
top 20.
let's go 19.
i didn't did not even realize
e3 out of 94.
i want to put the pawns like this
i'm just trying to optimize my pieces
uh maybe h5
good morning to europe
good morning from st louis as morning
for both of us just earlier morning here
[Music]
i want to do things
start with
in this move
do you want to play a4 at some point
oh it's going after the pawn
right here i think i can take
looks risky but
really
what's the highest rank you've ever been
in one of these marathons
also what's the highest finish you've
had
one moment
okay this is a losing but i'm going for
it because
there's still some ounce of hope
there's just one tricky eye and i was
looking at here here i have this move
double threat of this and this
also threatening this which
might be able to bail out but this
rookie 3 kind of hurts my plans oh
rookie 3 i take the rook
maybe it's okay
i mean here okay bishop d4 i can sack
i might go for this
and a draw would be a nice result in
this game
a tricky move
i think i'll play this
now a2 is hanging along with these ideas
rook t2
bishop e3 there's rook e3
i take
what it takes takes i think it's just a
draw
rook here i can take and then take
if you're ready for queen b7 then rook
f8
okay i think we're gonna
oh it's not a draw
i thought it was a draw but it's
is it it might be actually
the idea of rook
a2 if king e2
that's kind of weird
it might be a draw
raw
okay it's a draw
at least i didn't lose that
i gained a rating point i mean berserk
against a higher rate player and not
losing is a decent result
got some tournament points for that too
question is do i berserk the next game
i think that's my first is that my first
draw of the tournament
i think it is
okay i know this player deserves back so
i'm just working
i beat this player twice so far
different opening than previously
and d4 is slightly annoying
i have to take
the queen on c8
another annoying move
yeah this is not a good position for me
maybe i can get away with this
i'm gonna be losing at least upon if not
two
queen c7 wow
oh i'm just completely losing here
okay
i think opponent just missed it
but now i'm confused
i wanna play rookie two
oh no oh wait there's a before i take
and now i'm playing for a win
i think b4 is now a threat
because i'm controlling these squares
basically
a1 can always be controlled via the
check
uh yeah i'm not too worried about that
let me check
here we go
let's go okay
tricky position so white had actually a
pretty straightforward win
um
queen c7 i think was very strong
but here white can take this first
and then take
and then
just be up a bishop
so i was fortunate
got the win
the berserking continues 15th place
let's go
i should add top 10 to my bucket list
have yet to be the gm
hey ortho shop time
ortho schnapp is somewhere here
accomplished okay
so ortho schnapp against french it's fun
because
usually french players aren't used to
more open positions
i guess this is still
[Music]
like semi-closed
okay preventing bishop a6
and neither five is off limits
castle queenside looks interesting
uh
it will trail a bit
put the king on a1
king safety first
[Music]
like b4 i have queen of three
i can throw in this move
the queen f5 i'll play this
and queen c7 only move
i think i'll put the queen back
or get g7
oh there's an idea to play this and this
ring's tied down to c6 too
massive threat
wow it's a dork it's a discovered fork
let's go
okay black played too quickly in the
wrong moment there
let's go
okay
the 16th place
have a long streak of not losing
oh playing this opponent again
yeah we know tubbers work each other
if c4 i'll play e5 this time
appreciate the dork bits
i had this earlier
against the same opponent i kind of
forgot
i just want to be aggressive
maybe d5 incoming
is very dorky thank you tiny dinky daffy
okay v2 is the target
wow
i don't know what to make of this
position let's play this move
and maybe
let's just take
adaptive objectively it's probably not
so great for me but
it still looks playable
oh funny mine
this might backfire but i'm threatening
92.
now queen e7 threatening this
not really a threat though
hmm i have to take that
i'm down a lot of material here
first time resubbing with a new username
because you mispronounced it in a
naughty way the first four days
oh no
wait what did i say previously
now i'm so curious
okay i have to focus here
[Music]
oh
my king
i mean it's stalemate i should have put
my rook on d1 to start spike checking
good game first loss to that opponent
good player
what to do
dope is working now
let's have a
a reasonable game
oh let's play a danish gambit
no england
i just want a danish or scotch i guess
i'm playing a scotch now
or ponziani
how many openings can we play
in a single game
ah my pawn oh no
the pawn's still hanging
if take stars g5 quinn a4 but
thank you rhythmic
fifteen five appreciate that
okay so there's some ideas for black
thinking knight h2
[Music]
just avoid the nitrate
usually when you have more space you
don't want to trade minor pieces
i'll go for some
slow play
opponent wants to draw i don't want to
draw
that's not good for content
let's fight on
dig with rooker pawn i'll take it with
pawn
so now the file is open i have three
center pawns
my idea to shift everything over
maybe i'll start with this move ah but
then knight f6
i'll start with this
the queen is probably coming to
g5
play this
it takes i take with pawn queen g5 i'm
thinking knight f3
i'm realizing at some point
my eyes night my eyes might need a rest
my voice also might neither rest
it's a lot of talking
so i might play blindfold for a little
bit just to reduce the eye strain
i really want to play f6
let's do it
worst case i think it's a draw it takes
takes takes
when h5 knight g6 takes
i don't think i would take i'd play this
there's also this move immediately
but let's start with this
f5 is probably coming
oh that move i didn't see
there's
beautiful eyes
that doesn't work
mad lad eyes getting tired time to not
use them looking balls and just shoot
from the hip
wait what
oh that's 5000 bits
what about balls and hip and shoot
okay wait wait i have to focus
because uh
that's a crazy position i appreciate the
bits sheep something
you play this
i think i'll play this actually
just intuitive move
i'll build up pressure
now
f5 still probably coming
oh funny line if f5 i can take
here i play this
during the lift
[Music]
the idea of this and this
and box trying to like cocoon
go from a caterpillar to a butterfly
okay
we're working on optimizing the pieces
yes
[Music]
oh what is
this think i just go after the like 97 i
take
it looks wrong but
also kind of right
now i'm threading this
e5 might be coming e5 i take
his time is running low
also take with bishop there
it takes with bishop actually looks
better
we're trying bishop f7
[Music]
in somewhere
i do have increments so
i do i
i do
[Music]
a little bit awkward now
oh no
i losing i'm kind of losing
[Music]
ah
over pushed
really
i can't make use of my knight
still got a fight i have a nice bishop
monster bishop
and that move i like to see
these pieces don't really help protect
the king
[Music]
that's a useful move though
over c5
the queen check i block with a rook
first
living on the edge
literally
looking for this move oops
we made in one
trying to be resourceful here
oh not looking good
still fighting though
running b2 back in the rook
thanks for gifting subs
i'm on the verge of losing so i
appreciate the
soothing sound of subs being gifted
oh no my king
ah
game
oh it's so sad position look good i got
kind of tangled here
um
it was hard to untangle too because my
queen side down and knights pinned
so maybe taking
was not the best move
ah rook g7 hard move to consider but
just to trade and then win the pawn
good game though felt like i played the
early stage well
appreciate the raid alexandra samaganova
welcome welcome
if you're just joining
i am playing a 24-hour marathon
tournament
i don't know if i'll play the whole rest
of the tournament but we'll see
shout out to alexandra good luck with
the tournament
great to have some content we can watch
live from the eu
hope to see some great gambit lines
romantic face heart for the loss
oh thanks for that awk five
playing a strong player
so nop is working this time
just gonna get some
wireless opening queen's game declined
ipd7
[Music]
that's something similar earlier
95 i play knight g4
okay so i'm going for the the classic
plan h6
to get the bishop here
opponent is
yeah they started with rook c1 now
they're realizing they should go for a
minority attack
i'm already threatening bishop h3
uh this is a move
a nice little pork
in plus fork
and queen d2 i take
and then take on h3
just looking if there's anything better
here
considering that h3 but
oh there's also a bishop f5
which wins exchange
so many options
uh
yeah let's play this
loving your new youtube instructional
content cheers hey cheers thank you her
ready qualia
appreciate that
um
how to do this
bishop should probably move back
i want to open a file at some point
we're back with the bishop
guarding these squares
yeah i think i'll go for some f5
f5 f4
i don't want to take an allow knight e5
i have this move
yeah looming ideas of g5 now
which looks reasonable
looks a little bit risky but
okay takes takes knight h5
and then rook g6 i think
if take six knight d3 then i'm looking
at f4
takes takes knight t3
f4
that's also a move
i have to move back i think
i think generally when you're at the
exchange it still takes a lot of work to
win
it helps when there's an open file to
work with
so know h5 i'll play this
knight d3 maybe still f4
or maybe rook here first
is queen
h5 it might be a threat
there's also g4 which is interesting
which just shuts down everything
i kind of like g4 actually
it looks strange
a little bit anti-positional but the
point is
the knight can't easily access e5 if
only one of the knights can
and for time being e5 is guarded there's
no more queen h5
i want to do this trade rooks play this
lesson mate
um
oh there's almost a tactic
not quite i was thinking queen e4 but
i have to be patient
okay i'll go in with the rook
now i'm threatening this
that's a move
my plan is this and this
i don't mind trading
now this
trying to attack from all directions
from the center from the king's side
out from the queen side
eat some pawns
f5 is a little bit tender
i might actually end up sacking
although i could just defend too
looks simple enough
brooke probably wants to go back here
okay so now this i take
rook each one is off limits
this one leave ho shy
oh don't be people shy
or maybe you you can be people shy thank
you hannah sasse or hannah says
still learning your name appreciate the
the sub
okay i missed this move
i have this move
or saying uh queen trade
shout out to hannah
also thank you quittis
appreciate the gifted subs
it still takes work to win
i'm gonna hold on to the base of the
pawn chain
my rook has has to find a plan
maybe this
maybe this
it should be winning it might take a
while though
but i have time
okay so i'm over defending this pawn and
want to walk they came to b6
as a new plan and then target b4
and maybe
do things with the rook
the other rook
idea of this
this might be the the cleanest way
just give away f5
oh interesting
okay now i have a pass pawn
the knight takes i push
now you hear i play this
nice fork
there's e4 but b2
let's
go no tricks
and there's this move
there we go
defend the pawn first and then
go for the mate later
i orchestrate on poisson mate
[Music]
i was actually thinking like
is there the way
way to orchestrate on passante would be
something like this
this
actually i don't know how it would
happen when i could block
the king has a square
that would be tough anyway okay managed
to win
number 20.
staying above 2600
i did fall below for a moment
but picking back up i appreciate uh
the generosity
hummingbird bucker
greatest gifting five
hannah says welcome back
daffy higg
already qualia
okay
we have a
b6 isn't too common
it's playable
[Music]
okay i'm feeling good about this
now normally i would take or play
probably d5
h5 is coming very quickly
okay i have to keep pace here
it's not going to be like the previous
game where i have
lots of times to maneuver
so classic idea takes i would take with
rook
takes and queen g5 with
unstoppable mate
e5 happens so i'll take
and let's check
and bring the knight in
it's still a fight i mean rook f7
the knight's ready to come in
the square is a tremendous hole
and this move will also attack h7
also prevents idea of queen f7
black is maybe in trouble here
now the tricky part is staying awake and
not flagging
because i'm kind of drifting
i might need to give my eyes a rest at
some point
okay rook g7 i can either do this or
take first
okay let's take
now i want to bring the other knight to
e6
king takes interesting
maybe i'll bring my queen g6
yeah still very far away from meat
55 seconds
way 5 king b1
attacking e7 now
ready to come in with a knight
g4 was another idea which
maybe at some point i'll go for
yeah so knight e5 i think i play queen
h6 and then g4
and set up g5
i could have taken two
takes takes takes and then
eventually mating
okay queen here i have night here
now here i have this
now the queen and the knight are hanging
oh there's uh
[Music]
92 which i forgot about
i have to go for this
it'd still be okay but
i thought black was gonna play on
but black was in trouble
okay that was nice
let's go
18th place
trying to get back on a streak
um
stonewall type setup
on my castle queen side here
although my king's tied down to f7 so
probably not
maybe it takes and
it's interesting my g4
now would be the time to castle wow it's
sheep slapper
you sheep flapper
the slapper of sheep
gifting 50 subs that's crazy
[Music]
really really appreciate it
okay let's try this option slap some
sheep
and the the later it gets the harder it
is to talk
let's try to slap some sheep
starting with
f6 and now
f5
have a nice night
okay positional compensation let's go
don't hurt me
down a little bit of time
i have some nice position
or do i
it's trying to hurt me
um
i think i have to play this move didn't
want to play that move but
bishop there
back the thing
my king in
the feeling that would be coming
[Music]
oh no
let's try this
oh let's check how's that chuck ah my
queen ah
i feel like a sheep
that just got slapped
at le at least it was quick
and painful
[Music]
what to do
[Music]
yeah i was supposed to be the slapper
and not the sheep
thanks again sheepslapper
or no wait i'm not supposed berserk but
now it's too late
okay full tilt mode
i'll try and come back here
london time
oh joe bava london
now generally the knight is misplaced on
c3 in these positions
still playable though
i don't mind the pin
i think i'll um let's go back
some idea this and then eventually 94.
okay let's go
now i got the
smiley face structure
a kind of reverse stone wall
trying to control all areas of the board
if this i probably play this
the bishop back the visible hibernates
probably could have
taken but i don't want to trade off my
knight
we do trade i want to trade it on e4 to
get a pawn here
okay g5 might be coming
right now
i always have to consider this move
i probably do it
um let's do it
i want to get the h file
it still takes work
g4 was unexpected
yeah we're getting
a more locked structure now
i still want to go for this
maybe rook h4
and queen c5
yeah there's different ways to poke and
prod
27 is also an idea
now c3 is backwards too
[Music]
uh let's play this
idea takes in the bishop here
oh
start with this
not so clear
i want a pawn but
position looks a little bit shaky
yeah this isn't good
or is it
it might be good actually let's see when
i have d2
[Music]
but this pawn's hanging
[Music]
please take it
okay this is actually looking pretty
good
for a moment i thought my pawns were
going to fall my rook was out of play
but the pawns are
coming in clutch
23 next move
ah it's a funny position like rook's
gonna hang but c2 comes
right to c2
don't mess with these pawns
and there's rook d2 and i queen
i lose a rook but
it is winning
plenty of time
okay let's go
got the job done
thank you pulitz the wrapper
the sub with prime
thanks again the sheep person
okay
17th place
still gunning for top 10
[Music]
i am getting kind of tired
oh i'm playing the person in first place
i'm playing the person in the first
place
uh this is a bit sketchy but
okay now it looks pretty good
oh my pawns falling
or not
i can give up the queen
i'll keep the queen
feels like i'm getting outplayed here
oh it's not good
i'll play this
give up the bishop
now this is now just a really bad
position
we're trying to hold on though
yeah black plays as well
i liked the position earlier
ah that's neat
ah okay
that was a rough game
let's move on
[Music]
okay no berserking
playing something something vladimir
okay no berserking this could be a
longer fight than usual
i have this position earlier
it's something like this earlier
i played this line a few times so far
so white says that they want a shark
position
one of the benefits of not playing c6 so
early is i can play c5 in one move
which can be useful for these situations
also this is a key game i need to win to
cross back over 2600
wait what
was that work
oh that might work
it's interesting still
so i can play a queen a5
and then take on g2
or even rook
c8 yeah there might be some accidental
compensation here
so this is a threat
96 also looming
problem is i can't take on g2 and allow
the file to open
[Music]
so i just have to
deal with being down the pawn
[Music]
maybe i can
play 96 and 94.
is interesting
so calculating queen b4 takes takes 94
bishop b5
and maybe i throw in bishop a2 takes
takes with check
and then knight f2 in the end
is kind of cool
also g5 is there's a fork in the end too
[Music]
it looks playable
well that's actually kind of cool after
queen b4 takes takes knight e4 i'm
threatening this fork
and this fork
so all of white's pieces are forkable
i'm also preventing this because
oh that defends everything
very clever
maybe
this is no longer so great
i'm thinking f6
even some kind of f6 g5
wait what
it's such a random move
okay
um
and it does counter-attack the bishop
there's some logic to it
improve the rook
wow
i'm just losing now wow that's crazy
bishop c2 rook d5
i'm losing
ultra still trying to fight
well played though
okay here i can take and take on that
four
i'll also take here immediately maybe
i think
it's worth taking here immediately
try and confuse the opponent
94 bishop d5 i think i just play king
oh no
[Music]
knight f4 was not the best order i
should have taken first
we'll see what the white is up to
that was unexpected
bishop d5 was just easy win
at least here i have some hope
uh look here
these pawns are hard to touch
if this i play this and i win something
i think i think i'm winning now
yeah the knight or bishop
will be lost
okay a small miracle come back
let's go
i have to remember to stretch
celebration stretch oh it's very tricky
so white's hoping for this move so they
can hug my rook with everything
um
i have to be careful actually here
you're here
h4 check bishop f2
let's just not get the rook trapped or
hugged
yeah and i call off the king
things should be in the center
it still takes work though white's gonna
fight
um i kinda wanna play a5 b4
[Music]
now let's improve the rook first
okay let's move back change of plans
this will be really disappointing if i'm
not winning this
wow
be even more disappointing i'm losing
this which hopefully is not the case
i want to put white and zugswang
this somehow looks long actually after
bishop c3
i think this is wrong
oh no there's this move
it's close though
okay i'm taking a risk
it's actually very risky
um
oh no
i losing
am i winning i don't know
just was confusing
to play this
okay now i think i'm winning
what is this game
okay i'm definitely winning now
i better be winning
and this game
let's go
i think i was losing there somewhere
it's probably just a draw
it was kind of confusing though
oh white's winning
why he has winning chances somehow
okay white was winning after king e7
yeah
did i play this
king e6 and spawn's about turbo if i
play this
ah so yeah there's this line
and i can't trade off white's last pawn
crazy
okay
act to tournament
good morning to g spates
you're joining five hours and 45 minutes
late
oh i'm playing a gm
okay
uh gm in third place
nobody's working
i have not accomplished
uh my bucket list item of beating a gm
so
that's my first try
or first attempt
i have to unleash some london prep
yeah i'm not
stooping down to king's gambit this game
i already messed this up yeah i'm
supposed to play bishop uh b5
okay i'll try and transpose into some
main line
sorry
i keep confusing myself
pretty sure this is still
[Music]
sums for the main line
oh g4
it's kind of a new trendy idea to just
start pushing nate pawn when black does
this thing
in the london
so knight g5 i would take and
maybe go for h6
i'd like to castle
yeah if takes i take f6 knight g6
defends
now
[Music]
probably take first
i could take with queen now black would
have to take back and then knight f3
also take with pawn to prepare g5
also have 97 if i want to be
weird
choices choices
we'll take with queen
[Music]
f6 is probably coming otherwise g5 looks
very strong
probably want to throw in king b1
[Music]
trying to understand the situation on
the king's side like knight g5 takes if
this takes
queen g3
[Music]
go for some f4 idea
i mean there's also knight g5 knight h4
i think i'll go for knight h4 right away
if takes i have a choice what to take
back with
running the triple fork
or
this could get very positional
if queens are traded
thanks for subbing oh thanks for gifting
for the lugs
we could trade off knights
train of knights and then play f4
also thinking about f4 right away is
interesting
do that
because there's a case after takes takes
i can keep queens on the board
and go for uh g5 break
i mean takes takes rook c7 queen d3 b4
rook c1
interesting
maybe rook c1
[Music]
discouraging b4
rook c7 may be coming
between d2
[Music]
e7
yeah i think i'll
avoid the queen trade now
now going for g5
it takes
e4 is a move
it's not a move that was on my radar
previously
but the idea is just to smile
i want to take and play g5
some knight e4
i play g5 first
it's f5 2
let's go for f5
oh the pawn tension
i might be like just down upon at the
end of this but
the hope is that there's some
compensation
i'm probably worse here
morning this move though good morning
now finding this
in this move i constantly have to watch
out for
probably not working yet though
now it's harder for black to play b4
that's a fork
three nights
easy one at this point
okay
bucket list item complete
let's go
on the first try
tough game
it took
more focus than usual
[Music]
okay still looking to get top 10.
let's go
hovering around top 20.
thanks everyone for still being here
good morning to europe
yeah i appreciate people tuning in
oh playing dr martick
okay all berserk
this player has been high up for a while
now
danish gambit danish gambit
uh the danish gambit the kind
what is this
we just have an isolated queen's pawn
position
should be four is interesting
his pawns attacked
knights are happy
uh
[Music]
trade a lot
it takes a knight c4
euthorid mini dong
appreciate the thousand bits first time
viewer too
already cheering bits
thanks so much
okay d6 is a bit tender here
like to push my h-pawn
so making
[Music]
luft and now attacking d6 again
oh that's a blunder
yeah
i'm trying to get some accidental
compensation
i have to treat every blunder as a
gambit
that's a good move
making this move
up on time
i want to close things down
[Music]
this is not looking good
pick
defend
[Music]
it's gonna be a scramble
no
oh i allowed the rook trade was the one
thing i was not supposed to do
oh
good game
what to do
i was unfortunate
okay playing lorenzo person
okay no berserking
played once before
[Music]
i don't think we played this tournament
though
did we
i don't think so
okay south of gamba time
maybe
not quite a
stafford this is something though
uh it's a free pawn
white's just giving back the pawn
the c3 takes takes takes bishop e5 never
mind
there's queen b5 here
i'm happy with opening
because the queen is blocking the bishop
which is blocking the king from castling
rook t1 i win the pawn
and rook he8 is coming
oh we could trade queens or i could
checkmate
okay
that was nice
nice to have a game like that after a
tough
loss uh sometimes it's tricky to decide
between trading queens and mating
and this opponent is beating me every
single time
[Music]
but let's okay
i'll try and get revenge
and not get adopted
um
let's move
i'm allowing this but
black didn't want it
i want to do this
looks playable
xe3 i take b5
takes i take it back and defend
now it's just a better structure for
white
um
[Music]
maintain everything
you're threatening this now
wait my brook was hanging my rook was
hanging
i didn't see that
okay still a fight
risky move but
crying
not good
please have all the queen on please
please please
they probably had a auto queen on but
oh there is hope for still please please
please
there were so many hopes for stalemate
in that game
two occasions were black queen with
stalemate
oh
so close
i just didn't see my rook was hanging i
guess queen f3 was a good move because i
saw this threat
i just had to save my rook
live in a good position
off game
okay i guess i'll berserk
let's try and take this person down
staff stafford gambit time
yeah white's walking straight into the
trap
still prep
i think knight f3 is winning next move
if queenie won
let's go staffer gambit time i could
have taken the free bishop but
this is simpler
uh
[Music]
where's my win
[Music]
this and this i think are force made i'm
just deciding which one
is easier
i guess i'll go for this one
okay i was pleasant let's go
it's alpha gamma time
yeah this knight f3id is nice
i had this once before in a similar line
yeah it was actually a recent youtube
video
it was like beating title players
quickly with the staffer gambit
at almost exact same game in title
tuesday
okay
so still above 2600 still top 20.
hoping to stream together some wins
uh let's berserk i've never lost for
this player before so
hopefully the streak continues
but my opponent is working back
okay
so playing aggressively
new line for me
oh
that's why it's new
oh no my queen
i saw the center pond thing i didn't see
the queen thing
oh
okay i already had botes gambit on my
bucket list
i can add
who's a game in 10 moves
i'm so sad now what am i supposed to do
against this
wait i'm already worse there
queen d2 only move
to keep the advantage
okay that's good to know because this is
like very logical but i guess e5 is
strong
so queen g2 e5 and then
[Music]
h3 knight f6
knight f3 okay
or takes in queen e3
[Music]
interesting so some positional play
okay i'll be prepared for that opponent
next game
if we play again
[Music]
i know i know the rule don't resign if
you have a night i guess i had two
nights but
i lost my
my sense of hope
nobody's working player beat me before
i'm for revenge
also time for oh king's gambit is black
it's a folk beer counter gambit
the queenie 2 is like the main move
people play
um
i guess that's a move
so i can't take because bishop b5
i've never seen this line before so
i'm thinking f5
queen 2 castling
knight f2 looks a little bit risky
also looks interesting but
knight of two queen e2 king f8 rick f1
we trade
maybe that's the way to go
this bishop d3 i know is not theory so
it seems like the way to punish it
it looks like i'll get the bishop here
i'm looking at the line uh takes takes
c6 takes takes takes takes
right
down the pawn
but uh i have the bishop here but she
likes squared bishop
f9 takes i have bishop here
hmm
okay so knight c7 rook v8 the rook is
saved
white's probably going to look to
queen's eye castle
ideally
i would like to prevent that
might be difficult though
it's a good move too
i think i'm just going to be down
upon and then we'll fight
what to do
[Music]
yeah that's just not a good position
i don't have development
rooks are not connected
i think i'll play h5
rook like this and also
prepare uh
g4
it takes takes high with the h2 pawn
rook d7 is probably coming
so rook d7 i think i have rook e7
i'm just trying to get like a playable
end game position
maybe g6
knight d6 for cure
g7 coming
[Music]
and this move might hurt me
or that move
okay knight a5
doesn't look good but
trying to stay alive
the rook b5 b6 b4 knight b7
before now i have knight c6
g7
this looks terrifying but what to do
shift over
also f6 here
i'm just trying to resist
okay now he wants to come
to places
someday
f6 kh6 and
now i have this move
so takes takes etc
at least we're getting some imbalance
i have a now a kingside majority
of course white has a better queenside
majority
idea of this and this
or
this
so rookie 5i of f4
and there's g3 knight c4
rook here
back the knight
right here i have this
now i'm fighting mate and the rook i
might be winning now
weirdly enough
i think i'm winning
i have a rook for a night now
let's go
[Music]
also not plunder my last queenside pawn
[Music]
maybe this move
fixing the pawn
fixing both pawns
and then i want to walk up with the king
oh it's still going to be a race though
i think it's okay for me
slow white down
here there there
this should be fine
three moves till queening
knight lands on c8
oh
it's actually kind of tricky
i feel like rookie in that line
otherwise b5 b6
very sneaky
oh no my pawn please take it
i mean knight e4 is coming and then i'll
take
and if i need check i attack and then
win the pawn
oh but there's knight d3
em keeps going
i have king e3 coming
and then i'll win the pawn
with check and defend this pawn
there we go
uh might as well push
if i play this i got forked
object of the game is not to get forked
and now this pawns are gone there
okay well the game
oh so there's a very important moment
those end game and game nuances
why the end game is important is like
one wrong move can spell disaster so if
i take the knight too soon
then white's winning after b5
and i just can't stop the pawns
so rook c it was very timely
i'm wondering if maybe i should have put
my king here to avoid the potential
knight of four but
probably both moves we're winning
okay thank you queasel flumming with
prime
i was worried so man this game i was
just down the pawn and suffering for
most of that game
[Music]
but life goes on
okay
let's move
game feeling good thank you samuel
new prime sub
i mean there's two moves here or three
moves
or four moves
already pleasant
oh i just kind of lost a pawn though
but black takes it then it gets spicy
okay now it's kind of looking a bit more
dry but it's still very solid
put the queen on e4
challenge the c file probably want to
play this soon
yeah the bishops work really nicely
together rook c7 may be coming
throw an h4 for good measure
and start the gobbling
um that's a move
you just want to take and
bring the queen in and then the bishop
in
i guess we can trade and b2 is lost
not so simple
[Music]
okay six in the end
i'm calculating check and then rook a6
ah but f2 is hanging
i have king g3
i guess i'll play king g3 just defending
the pawn
okay it's getting kind of weird
i'm also kind of getting low on time
i'm envisioning some king walk where the
king helps with mating
we can trade queen side pawns
flag wants
i should keep queen f3 in mind
okay so i'm inducing g6
now i want to lock the king here
nigel short style
um
play this move
each word is
defended i have to throw in queen g5
[Music]
okay i'm going oh it's not working ah
i saw um i saw a queen e2 queen g4
i didn't see that though
how bad is this
this is pretty bad
um
not quick enough
please queen please please please
okay
oh
i had to calculate the stalemate
oh this could have been beautiful
i missed queen f2
that was a bad move to miss
um
[Music]
that could have been cool
[Music]
there's also i mean there's a funny line
to play this
immediately
between g4 and then king here
and walk up this way
but i wanted to get to h6 which is
not so easy to do
okay 19th place
playing dirty flagger cavall
[Music]
ip once before
do i berserk
that's not berserk
i don't want to get dirty flagged
like to go for a
a stafford
oh this line so this line i'm going to
take with night
with knight take with knight
oh this is tricky line if i play this
there's this move which
i don't want to deal with
but maybe i i'll just deal with anyway
it's a crazy line
bishop's e4
and then i believe knight f2
and f2 are bishop f2
already forgetting i think it's knight
f2
mizuba 7 the king ends up going to g6
yeah there's like there's some
opening theory in this line which i've
not looked into in a while
i know at some point black is supposed
to play h6
but i
i don't know what i'm doing here
oh no
i'm 27
maybe dc d6 looks normal
i mean my king's on g6 which is a bit
abnormal but
i think a niche gary played this once
have to look on my youtube channel
i have a video from years ago
[Music]
it's called something like a nishkiri
petrov loses in 20 moves
i forget if anish was i think he was
black and he lost
was b4
so i can play back
there's this move too
which i should at least consider
i think i'll just move back
okay so i'm preventing knight h4
also preventing the queen checks
now i'll just develop as if
everything is normal
oh it's called beating a niche gary's
petrov defense in 22 moves
i'll have to rewatch that video
i think i made that like two and a half
three years ago
the early days of my youtube channel
beginning to feel a bit more comfortable
minor pieces developed
we end up trading
[Music]
like to trade queens now
okay now i'm just trying to remove the
knight from defending the other knight
i mean there's this crazy move
threatening this
i'm calculating this takes takes king h5
i mean i'd probably just play rook g8
after queen c3
i am up the exchange and the pawn
i guess that's the risky thing about
this line for white is if white doesn't
mate me
and doesn't win back material
and black is that material
a g4 oh i didn't see g4
that's probably a really strong move
i want to play this move
problem is after takes takes rook g1
what's going on
i have e3 too
maybe e3
doesn't seem to accomplish much though
x
g4 is very resourceful
i also kind of want to play rook f8
maybe i just taken king h6
this looks so terrifying
oh no oh actually queen g5
maybe i'm still alive
this looks really bad
rook f8
i want to take the pawn
funny line queen f4 g5 takes with
discovery check but then i take the
queen
another funny line rook here g5
never mind
i have to play g5
oh no g5 doesn't work
i'm just losing
i don't see a way out of this
i didn't see a way out
that's probably just losing
am i just getting made in next move
yeah it's just forced me that's crazy
there's no way out
g4 was such a good move
yeah best move
i was slightly better
actually it's really complicated still
[Music]
how much of that was theory
uh i don't think i'm too upset about
that game opponent played perfectly
at least in the end
but probably not earlier though
in one blunder
oh knight d2 is wondrous
yeah these positions are hard to
understand
yeah definitely not an engine user
probably knew the line and
g4 is very findable
i did have my chances in the middle game
okay back to tournaments
outside the top 20.
uh let's research eat this player before
oh it's a london yeah i remember that
game
so opponent's actually switching up the
opening this time
his opponent also resigned against me
like didn't even try and dirty flag me
earlier so
they might have too much respect
i'll go for this 95 line
so
i think previously i had the the game
against the gm
[Music]
97 i think i just played this
i'm going to say c5 i have bishop b5
check
uh that's a blunder due to this
this isn't my london tactics course
i think the london command still works
should link to the course
in boxing black is going all out for uh
some
complications i just have to keep my
calm
[Music]
i was thinking takes in bishop e2 bishop
g4 f3
i also have knight g5 bishop e2
i have to deal with h6
let's go for this
oh this is actually not so good
i forgot about rookie eight
okay
it's not the move i want to play but
i think bishop e2 is just much worse
the leg bone cloud
oh no
my queen
[Music]
okay i need a miracle here
and i beserk this game
so what do i have for it
i have a rook
and a dark for bishop
[Music]
um
[Music]
try and confuse things
it's completely lost
trying to confuse my opponents
slightly surprising option there
oh oh i was
i didn't have increment i completely
forgot about the time
i was gonna try some like pre-move thing
but uh
like there's a funny pre-move trick
uh
i just didn't have enough time to set up
laughter takes
um
to then play a6
hoping that black would be expecting
this to pre-move king e5
but after uh
this if this is pre-moved then white's
winning
um
it was one last trick but wasn't quick
enough
okay no more berserking
uh playing doctor chess alouy oh that's
berserk if opponent deserves i believe
back
and i play stafford
no stafford this time
that's a funny line takes in d5
okay so i have the bishop pair
probably slightly preferable position
going after this pawn
yeah this looks very pleasant
go for this move
i have to take
so up upon
i have to use my king as a weapon
my knight's very restricted here
oh i kind of messed up
it should still be winning but
probably should not have allowed that
i'm up on the fonzo
interesting
go eric
hey that's me okay
let's go
thank you mike sullivan and michael luck
a five-month-old baby
hey
happy five months
even though it's 14 months yeah you were
born five months ago
okay uh
yeah this is a decently strong player
previous game
i lost
or no previous game i won
i'll play this line
that's a playable line
going for bishop g2
so white has a bishop here black has a
slightly better center
probably go for bishop g5
maybe some queen a4
expecting this move
that move
trying to be solid
[Music]
i have this move
xc2 i take b7 if takes takes
got the a file
[Music]
b4
i mean some idea to play b5 and win the
pawn
a lot of options here
and the rook wants to be on d1 clearly
let's do this
thinking 92 next
there's also this move
there's also rook a4 maybe you're okay
for
just to double up
pressure the knight as well
now if i double up there could be a
threat of b6
wow
okay let's start with this
smelling c4
in the near future
i'm just trying to destabilize i mean
this is a great example of x-ray vision
of this i can play knight d2
a five hangs upon
if this i just taken win the knight
the thread is probably just takes bishop
takes and takes on e5
that's interesting
i mean i could save the bishop but
just go for the
[Music]
win of material
there's also a funny move
takes takes and rook team one
though takes higgs rook to e8
and then some kind of night move
ah but then there's this check
on d1
wait no i can leave the bishop
i think this works
okay so calculation takes takes let's
say rook ad1
and then knight h4
so i prevent f5 i unleash the thing
that move i missed
ah i have this move now
and black's still under a ton of
pressure
i don't think knight c5 was good
now this and this are hanging and
pieces are not in good shape to defend
hey gary's still here
oh gauri fell asleep
uh
can
take take and take on e5
this looks nice
rook's now hanging pawn's still hanging
both captures come with check
let's start by taking here
there's 97 i take
or
coming i have two sets of double pawns
they're not too weak
i think the simple plan is just to get
the pawn to g6 trade rooks
and then promote
rook here
and maybe just h3
or this first
i have to be a little bit careful though
okay this should be pretty simple
[Music]
the pawn is too far
okay pretty clean game
oh that's actually one way of resisting
though
this move
and then this
and classic tactic
i guess i could have also taken the rook
works just as well
let's go okay
nice game
167
the leader has 285
so the leader is like berserking every
game it looks like
which might be a better strategy
okay let's please work because i want to
do
if i win the game i berserk
and try and get the best working streak
of course there's risk but
i have to deal with the risk
no time to hesitate
i think it's already a good structure
usually against the stonewall
the problem for white is i have f6 and
white doesn't have f3
of course it's still a fight
[Music]
oh that was tricky
did not have allowed that
okay well now i'm just worse
oh it's so sad too
please move
um
i'm just trying to get some kind of
practical chances
oh maybe this and c4
and now these pieces are all stuck
can i trap the queen
i mean it's kind of hard to trap
maybe i trade queens it seems weird
to trade queens when being down a lot of
material but
it's easier to play
oh no i just i'm giving away pawns
okay i still want to trade queens
with me
i'm not too optimistic here i should
probably just resign
[Music]
but i'll try and fight
never resign when you have a knight
[Music]
i'm really trying here
applying pressure
there's actually a lot of pressure right
now somehow
i don't know how this happened
i think this
opponent has so much time though to like
deal with this
it's crazy i only have 11 seconds
in no increment
what is like going to play like queen
jack king h7
queen c2 i take
we want to meet
it should be winning now
time is tricky
okay so no checks
i've missed that
built running mates
not too much hope now
i have to survive 50 moves
that's the only way
oh i'm so sad
oh
what's that game
opponent just wondered their rook
what was that game
[Music]
those 100 moves too
okay let me put on my heart rate monitor
i'm gonna break after that one
i was also probably just meeting um at
some point
uh i was crazy to like fight back from
such a position
like white really
really was trying to let that one go
was it forced mates
in five after rook h2 that's hard to
find though
queen g3 is more natural
but i guess reggae shoe makes sense
i think you get t
and sovereign uk
appreciate the subs
okay uh
yeah look at this game
[Music]
it's probably one of the lowest quality
games of the tournament so far at least
for me
okay
the chest doesn't stop
opponent from
earth or bullet rating
wow very high bullet rating that's crazy
probably some anonymous title player
i did blunder upon there but
box not taking it
i'm just going to try and play solid
this game
oh pimmy is top ten thousand oh no
you're right on my tail
are there 10 000 there's probably 10 000
players in this tournament by this point
some idea to do things
i'll put the queen
the more aggressive square
defending the pawn
have to allow the trade
maybe i could have played bishop t2
actually probably a good move
i take
take and play e5
i mean b2 is a bit tender but
nice attacks
i should probably take a move to the
fend
i'm balanced
and i have three maybe could on poisson
yeah no on poisson
i just want to go for this and do things
i might end up playing e6 actually
h6 was logical
so e6 there's g5
let's go for it
leads to kind of an interesting
structure
now the knight wants to come here
if i take
let's take
so holding onto the pawn
maybe this move
and g5 is coming though
this move
not entirely clear what i'm doing here
king h1
okay taking some risk i mean there's a
line takes takes takes
i'm hoping for some move
box not going into it
i'll probably queen f2
okay
defending attacking
i'm not sure what my plan is but i'm
also not sure what black's plan is
so i'm just trying to hold my ground
before maybe
[Music]
maybe gave black a weakness to
target i do have this move now
hitting e7 and also a5
and knight guards e1
yeah these pawns nicely restrict the
bishop
queen d1 coming or e5 coming
hard to stay awake and focused same time
[Music]
this move
i think the trade is winning for me
okay now this i have this and this
is really risky for black
um
i'm trying to win i might end up over
pushing and lose but
will be a better story to tell
okay that's a draw
i assume it's
it's probably a draw the whole time
because my king doesn't have enough
shelter
oh it's winning how's it winning
28
and it says to repeat and then after
king here
oh a5 i mean this is what i did though
oh i put the queen on d7 let's go
so apparently i have to put the queen on
e7
i don't fully understand this
i guess with the queen here then
i'll say queen
[Music]
d2 uh then i avoid perpetual
that's hard to calculate
i guess i do maintain the threat of 96
so
okay
thank you aka moth
another draw
um okay i'll try and string together
some wins
i feel like berserking next game no
matter what
i also feel like playing aggressively
e4 time
i don't think opponent was expecting d4
already very pleasant position
on d5
at kind of a tense position
and now i have c3 looming
i might not be better here but
play for something
[Music]
i want to go for f5
i need to take and take
and the bishop f4 now
use some f6 ideas
and i just want to trade and mate
i defend the pawn this queen f6 was a
threat
and now
how does black defend
i don't think black can defend
i think it's completely winning
yeah there's no stopping this
pre-move this
oh that's a move
okay wait it's not
over i should still be winning though
i'd rather be winning
[Music]
i'm threatening to take and mate
okay that was nice
black almost survived but not quite
okay berserking win
back on track top 20 again
uh i'll just work again
oh
i was not expecting knight c3
so i'm playing the budapest against the
verisoft opening
it looks playable
yeah this is probably worse than a real
budapest
i'll try and make it work
i don't mind if bishop a6 is played
going for this move
use some bishop b6 ideas
the alignment is kind of unsettling but
i have to deal with it
i kind of awkward pawns
just trying to hold my ground
put the rook in
okay getting something playable
probably want to shift back over to the
c file at some point
oh it doesn't
work f5 also coming
though maybe i can get away with this
f5 i have king of six rook here and then
this
looks
okay maybe this first
just trying to hold on
[Music]
i feel a bit stuck here
might as well play king f6
go for b5 b4 rook c3
of a5 rx c5
f5
i'll have to deal with it
okay now i have this idea for k1
also this to defend
sideways
dangerous position
this i have to play the
[Music]
i should have taken
so playable
doesn't look good though
um
i have one second left what is this
opponents taking their sweet sweet time
[Music]
still fighting
barely
what to do
yeah well i played well that game
actually
kind of milked the end game
like a cow
[Music]
i think after f5 i'm just losing
yeah very difficult position
screenplay
maybe it made sense to play h5 sooner
just maintain the center pawns
okay
back to tournament thank you maloon jam
loving with prime
that's a risk of berserking
speaking of deserting okay
if i play someone sub 2200
it makes sense berserk
again the goal is top 10
which i
kind of within range
29 points away
i'm just trying to get like a quick win
[Music]
oh no my pawn
okay so black fell for a nice opening
trap
it's already losing for black
the queen's attacked and now i win the
rook
so this is one of the reasons for
berserk
is to
have a game like this where
uh
opponent falls for a trap i get extra
tournament points
i guess i still have to
running one two
i have
six different mates in one
okay yeah that kind of castle queen sign
i mean black did trap my queen though
some success
let's go
okay 19th place
yeah rook b6 took the least amount of
effort
there i forget if this opponent believes
back
hopefully
this looks like a fun london
okay berserk's back
might be winning a pawn already
or not no we're just trading
hmm
okay let's have some fun i'm throwing
mate in two
it's made in two let's
go there's a reason to play h4
is to set up the mating threat so if it
takes it's made king hear its mate
a nice little idea
um i mean black should probably take but
i was looking to get some counter play
there maybe bishop here and then rook
lift
okay oh did i miss a free bishop
i may have missed a free bishop
yeah you're probably right everyone who
wait let's see
oh yeah because ba5
wait
i did
i missed a free bishop
yeah the queen's not getting trapped
i even saw that too
and then i just thought we're trading
but it worked out
if i took the bishop i would probably
would not have had that mate
okay back to tournaments
so that's two in a row
it was working 177.
oh
okay pulling berserks
say something solid
94 coming
that's already unpleasant
and that was a small surprise
i want to play this but it's not working
[Music]
queen aid is a massive threat
i'm just losing here
i'll try and fight though
oh there's a funny idea there's a really
funny idea
white didn't fall for it of course
i have to share after the game
i'm still fighting though
it's not over
somehow
with pawn on f6
this should be a draw
no i'm losing okay
on this rook b5
[Music]
oh white's playing for a dirty flag
now i'm playing for a win
let's go
this is now winning
let's go okay
how did i win that i was getting smashed
i was getting absolutely smashed
look at these pawns
there's a funny idea
uh
if takes
it might still be winning for white
actually but uh this this move double
attack the rook
both brooks
this is winning for black
um
yeah then the end game
i guess f6 was very timely
it wasn't so simple for white
it should still be winning but uh
okay
so that's three in a row is working
uh never played this opponent before
grand master do i know this person
i don't know this person okay no
berserking
i don't want to observe someone high
rated and higher titled
oh yeah e5 is probably coming so
bishop d2
idea knight d5
looking for queen a2
i still want to play this
that allows knight b5
i think i should just go for then c3
now there's takes an a4
maybe bishop's e2
yeah the bishop's happier here
i just want to make my pieces happy
one
rook is happier
i need this idea
in bishop d3 there's c4
i can play c4 myself which
is actually very logical
[Music]
the night has a hard time eric was so
engrossed watching the swan mask ultra
bullet vod i missed the start of the
stream oh no
[Music]
that's kind of funny
well thanks for being here awkward night
i could take and
deal with this
i can take some bishops he won
i want to maneuver the knight
i mean black has the same idea
rook
rook e3 and bishop d2
love to distract the queen
also bishop h6
in cases
it might be playable right away
and your rook d6 in the very end
let's try it
yo low time
so the idea is i hit the knight queen
has to move and then i have this move
and things will be attacked
i also might want to throw in this move
to defend the pawn although i should not
be playing defensively
yeah this is probably just bad for me
okay let's try this
still believe
and knights coming to d4
was just a bad sacrifice
do this move
oh my bishop is so sad
okay let's try this move
there's rook t8 53
and this was part of my original idea
for this move
ah there's a bug ah
bug was just flying in my face
hey what is this
uh
of this move
there should be one coming
that's material
wait black has broken two nights for the
queen
it's not good
maybe gone out oh no
i still have a queen black doesn't have
a queen
in this move
something to fight for
[Music]
i think attack if takes of course
um
[Music]
this could be tricky for black to win
because i have the pawns
do i check
rook or no i don't
oh so
oh
i got excited for a moment there
i can try and use my pawns
and this this
so if takes i have h6
and the dream is to win the bishop and
just have the queen against the two
rooks
keeping an eye on all the targets
and now it's hard to resolve the pin
[Music]
the rooks are a bit disconnected
this idea is hard to stop
it's falling apart
i could have taken an e5 too
google's not the flag
of sad
it should be four was completely winning
[Music]
okay i resign
what to do
i felt really close to being salvageable
but maybe it's
and it's always better for black
so here a queen g5
and then there's some repetition
almost came back
the sack wasn't so good
[Music]
oh maybe it was playable
[Music]
a4 hard to find
yeah there is no need to sack
i just 93 and play positionally
okay back to tournaments
182 18th place
i wonder how many viewers have like
fallen asleep
to the stream
and still count as a viewer even though
they're unconscious
kind of hard to measure
okay i beat this opponent twice before
wait a minute i don't know what i'm
doing here
i don't know why i'm going into this
line
well this is just a bad line
oh no
maybe it's not so bad though i need to
take
oh this is pretty bad
[Music]
or is it
it doesn't look so good
don't hurt me
a check doesn't do anything i have this
move
have this move
the dream is to trap the queen
i have to play this move though
the dream is also to not get mated
oh we're at the seven hour mark
i take
wait let's just offer draw
draw
ah let's play for a win
oh no my pawn
well he's playing really quickly which i
mean there might be opportunity to
punish in some way
hoping for c4
the lucky 13 four leaf clover four leaf
clover four leaf clover
appreciate the lucky 13
you king abdul toronto
also what is this position
[Music]
okay i'm just losing here unfortunately
i have a night an octopus night
i also have 19 seconds
i have to run out of pawn moves is the
first step
that's unfortunate
you never know though
you never know
[Music]
you never know
it's still meat
why did i smell
smell stalemate coming
there are so many ways for white not to
stalemate
but there is also
a way for white to stalemate
that's why you play on kids
that's why you play on
appointment had more time than they
started with two
okay
seventeenth place let's go
is working
let's try and use that as momentum and
energy
also thinks oh no my queen 11 subbing
for three months
and zako
also for three months
yeah c4 is a bit unusual maybe it's
playable
[Music]
i'm still happy with the position though
um
yeah i'll try and get some quick attack
trying to get a more controlled attack
but also a quick attack
so now here i'll go for this idea
if that
want to punish this but
it's not easy to punish
i'm just going for 93
i have this move
so threatening the knight
and the pawn
if this i
might take
okay this is looking really pleasant now
the problem for black are these squares
and then prospect of the knight coming
here
queen coming here
welcome back ravenous crab crab
i was gonna ask what sounds do crabs
make but they probably just say crab
especially ravenous crabs
yeah this is really really pleasant
this is going to be really hard for
black to cover the square
right here
[Music]
i think i would start with this
uh actually no i have to take
i have to take
wait do crabs not have vocal cords
they're incapable of talking
okay plan is to go after this pawn
it's defended twice
but i can attack it up to three times
also what is this pawn structure
it reminds me of go
[Music]
like beginner game of go
yeah this is undefendable
king is surprisingly safe on d2
now hitting the bishop threatening this
now threatening made in one
remember workout seven prolongs a game
but okay
it's nice
trying to rack up the points 17th place
so how many people ahead of me are
paused
looks like
three
oh playing this person
this player played a good game that
previous game
oh they beat me on the staffer that
previous game
let's play something more solid
i'mana
play taimanov
i haven't played sicilian in ages
yeah we played a while ago
i'm playing my tournament repertoire
opening queen c7
this is why i play in like real chess
there's a line bishop e3 but
this is considered to be fine for black
i see seven i'll i'll lose my
queen oh no my queen
and then the i'm still in prep i mean
queen g4 is the main line
and
there's a book by delchev
all about taimanov and he recommends a
almost novelty after queen g4
main move would be g6 but delgive
recommends bishop e5
idea after bishop e5 f4 there's knight
f6 which is really cool
a4 is kind of random
so this will be fun this is uh three
minor pieces against a queen
um
generally i'd prefer the three miners
okay we could trade
maybe this move
trying to be active i do want to unleash
this bishop someday
controlling the square
i want to allow c4
how to do this i could maneuver the
night
potentially
maybe a decent idea
so one benefit when you have multiple
pieces for a queen they can work
together to
control squares multiple times
the downside of the queen it's only one
piece
even though it's a powerful piece
okay so i'm envisioning a setup where
i have a knight here we trade maybe
pawns and rooks i put the bishop here
and this defends this defense's
defense's defense this defends this
i think i start by taking
so i'm losing the
eight pound in the end
but i get this construction
[Music]
that's a really nice chain of defense
the question is can i play this for a
win
also the rook wants to come in and hurt
me
when i get hurt
maybe h5
making luft and
someday dreaming of some attack
g6
in h4 there's queen e7
[Music]
wondering if i can
walk around
rook 8 i think i just played bishop here
that's a funny position
you've already been subbing for three
months
this might just be a draw
unfortunately
yeah i want to play for more but
maybe white will play for more
wow
[Music]
okay so there's bishop d8 here
and i'm controlling b6 now
the bishop wants to return
i'm gonna play this for a win
though
white having perpetual
i have to be really careful not to get
forked too
i was good at forking things
as long as i can stay up on time
this is going to be a long game
my plan is to put the bishop here walk
the king around probably put a pawn on
g6
and then eventually when the b5 and then
c3 pawn and then queen this pawn
very long term plan
um
[Music]
on the pin stuff
hey let's try it
when you're right i fork
can't remember the last time i saw
someone so focused but so handsome too
okay
do the juwat
okay g6
okay so now everything defends
everything except the bishop's
undefended but that's okay
uh
it's really
asking for trouble i have this move now
working the fork and the pawn
yeah so this and this are threats
if this i discover
discover when the queen
looks like i'm winning the pawn
i just have to be careful that i don't
lose anything
let's take that
now with running this pawn
i want to play this move
no draw
i don't know why i was doubting myself
there so queen f6
the simple plan is to
[Music]
play this
g7 win the pawn
and be very patient here
a really difficult position for white
play this too
[Music]
move
this
it takes work it's work
i like my chances though
it's a fun position to play
i just want to keep everything defended
basically so pawn's defended
king is safe
has enough shelter
um now probably this move i'll get the
pawn to d2
pushing
and now bishop e3 will be lights out
or check and then bishop b3
okay that was nice
i thought it was going to take more work
but
got the job done
it was a fun game
that's a nice kind of demonstration of
the coordination of minor pieces
you did everything to work together
okay 17th
place oh playing first place
okay no berserking because they're in
first no mercy
i'm i'm fed up with losing to this
person also i wait i beat this person i
beat this
person it was a stafford name from
earlier i forgot about that
what am i doing
c4 is not the move but
i'll try and make it work
oh
it's already trouble
[Music]
i have this move
okay have a playable position
let's not trade queens
um
well played
come down the piece here
pleasant
am i winning
it's really close to winning
as far as me wow or no it's not worth me
it's it's interesting
to say the least
i'm down over rook what
[Music]
maybe
hey it's a counter check
me hey
i was waiting for my rook to block one
of the checks
but such a funny mate
or d4
walking into a pin
attack three times but it's counter
check
okay took down the person in first
arm some rating 14th place let's go
at some point i'll take a break
but i'm not going to take a break when
i'm on the streak
i have to keep it going
in gregory
a london time
okay so this is a
already pleasant luncheon for black
better remove orders knight d2 instead
of c3
ah this is what min lei plays
um
i think i prepared takes knight h5 for
him
idea to
gradually develop
i take a 20 minute power nap
or
if i turn into a swan i still have my
swan thing
i could play one game as a swan
at some point
someone
should remind me later though
i don't feel like turning into a swan
now
also i observed i have to move quicker
e5 probably coming soon
a nice position
[Music]
i have the center very soon i can grab
the bishop hair
it's only slightly better for black but
most i can ask for
[Music]
preventing b4
eventual idea of h4
my plan is like we need seven h4
or h4 right away
and i want to play bishop e5 king g7
rook h8
oh there's a funny mate
although
well i probably wouldn't allow it
there's a mate like this where i play
queen h1
uh knight h1 and then
bishop h2 mate
but there would also be queen h2
immediately
now it's in trouble here
uh free thing
i like free
okay that's nice
i'm trying to get back to 2600
also trying to finish top 10
also trying to get 200 tournament points
maybe i could do all of this all of the
things in the one game
[Music]
okay
play a black mustang
reverse grand prix
already a strange position
don't mind this
and the pawn
wow
knight c7
okay it's getting confusing if g5
maybe bishop e5
the h6 for good measure
it's getting really confusing
i have bishop d4
i might as well
play now the knight's trapped
oh it's not trapped what is this
uh let's play this move
just leave the knight there
stick with this
[Music]
oh no
yo
my position
oh it was a tricky game
rookie seven was a good move
although
no i can't play that because bishop
takes
yes losing what to do
yeah rook t2 bishop takes d2
okay back to tournaments
i don't get my rating or my 200 points
or my top ten
still close though
okay i'm berserk
what's the line here
consistent in this
yeah we can get a funny structure
as interesting pawn chain
just have a pawn showing on g6
after
[Music]
in my territory
it's a little bit unpleasant
this and this
well
i take no i can't take
i think i'll take here
the rookies have an idea
yeah this should be preferable for
whites
[Music]
okay let's go
got the job done
it's a fun endgame
okay
i haven't played this opponent before
so this is a reverse grand prix attack
ideas are very similar to the normal
grand prix
e6 is weirdly typical
[Music]
i might play more positional actually
depending what light does
yeah my plan is to put this on youtube
[Music]
um
if you're watching in the future on
youtube and you've made it till this
point
congratulations
this should be around the eight hour
mark
i'm so proud of you
[Music]
let's play this move
if you've made it to this point uh leave
a comment
time stamping your favorite moment of
the stream
[Music]
i also intend
to put timestamps for every game
every opening oh
[Music]
oh wait let's play this move
i have to be careful here
oh my god
i'm just worse
um
pawn's falling
hole positions crumbling
i have this move knight f3 maybe
then bishop e6
still some fight
king age one is slightly surprising
and calculate take 6
g2
i play this move it's weird but
the prospect of queen c6 is really nice
the key doesn't really have a great
place to hide
also controlling e1 and the e-file
if i get this in that i'm threatening
made in two and the dork
discovered orc
okay
it was worth taking a extra moment to
find the right move there
oh it's not over
queen defends
oh no i'm probably gonna lose this
so i can pull some miracle
workout for
writing queen f3
preventing this attacking this
all looking good let me fight them
oh final position too
i really thought it was going to be easy
when
after queen c6
f4 was a great find though regarding g2
starting g2 and f3 simultaneously
that wasn't so simple
so better move
yeah like d5 is kind of weird
it's a great position
a lot of ways to win just slow play
h5 eventually
okay what to do
[Music]
it was a funny finish
again that's the danger of
[Music]
berserking had my chances though
i'm still fighting for top ten
[Music]
oh first place is finally paused
uh okay let's play this line
of g4 let's play this
i'll admit i'm out of any sort of book
but this looks like a playable position
we're both losing casting rights i have
the bishop hair which is nice
wow castling that's a funny move hahaha
oh i forgot that was illegal
[Music]
i still have the bishop here bishop z5
is probably coming
now black's under some
pressure these ideas looming
measure b5 coming
a lot of pressure here
this is the power of the vision pair
they control a lot of squares
when they work together
the question is how to
maximize
maybe this move
idea just to double up
rook d2 there's bishop h6
and now i was thinking this
now there's no more g5
yeah there's a lot of threats here i
mean this is a threat
c6
i think the simplest way is just to take
aches in bishop b5 z7 rook e7
not the most glamorous but gets the job
done
enforcing moves
okay
got the job done
15th place
i'm close i'm in four points away from
tenth place it looks like
oh playing vladimir again play this move
okay so black mustang
this is now uh
chagoran chagoran
i think takes an e5
and this is some line
not a line i've studied before but it
looks fun
oh bishop b5 is coming
am i already losing
i might already be losing i have queen
e7
which is kind of
just not working
oh this kind of backfired
there's this move
this move is actually kind of
interesting
takes takes here and then bishop b4
you're treating this as a gambit
idea takes takes then f3 hangs if queen
takes
and now these things are attacked
okay i could castle
that's most logical bishop h3
king b8
here i can take
okay so now i'm making this work
i should have been losing but
i probably still am losing
at least it's interesting
okay i was about to blunder in knight
d3
h5
queen g5
i gotta watch out for this pawn
[Music]
the queen should probably be on uh b6
i played this with tempo
there's also this idea
i guess it depends if i want to play
pawn z6 or queen b6
like maybe this offers me better chances
to stay aggressive
queen here
not a great sign if i'm going for a
queen trade but
okay if takes takes on h4 is weak
i do have three pawns for the piece
yeah i'm sorry nightbot is not
fully working
[Music]
also thank you for
everyone's subbing i see we have 200
subs this stream
203
i think ravenous crab was the 200th
wait
let's start with this move
i want to take
and now white wants a queen trade
maybe play d3
i have to be careful pushing the pawn
too far
and d3 looks interesting
idea d2
hey zippy what's up zippy
that's frozen rosen i hope i haven't
been freezing too much
i have this move
no queen trade for you i want to play
this
attack multiple things
that's very logical
might as well go for this anyway
a zippy bring back the maker move
tts lull
wait what is that make a move tts
oh make a move
i think i still have that extension
[Music]
yeah
or gotham or her car will yell at me
i'd rather not be yelled at right now
also what am i doing here
you rookie two
you two work
probably doesn't work
defend
you conflabatory
for the 12 13.
maybe in the next game i'll enable the
extension also i missed a free pawn
f6 idea
i'm preventing knight e4 knight is very
restricted here
this i play this
trying to gain a little bit of time back
i don't mind the trade
i don't think
a funny position now
i do this this
king d7 clutch move
what
now it's completely winning
let's go
i'm in berserk right i have increments
i have increment
let's go
okay somehow i won that
i was scared because this is a big
threat and if i have to move over i lose
this pawn
but thankfully i found uh i played g3
first and found this and
g7
white kind of freaked out
it's actually really beautiful the
knights completely stuck
pawns did their work
okay back to tournament
14th place
oh first place is unpaused
on a losing streak
berserk
hey it's thomas franson good to see you
apologies if it's hard to
interact with chat
it's hard enough like staying awake and
trying to play these games
but i'm doing my best
okay stafford gabba time
wait what
that's a funny move
if takes out there's this move
i kind of want to play this
and insist on the stafford
well with a bishop on d4
it's getting kind of weird
if knight f3 i take him in the pawn
[Music]
okay this is exactly what i wanted
because now
white's in trouble
[Music]
i think white's in big trouble
[Music]
bishop's not happy here
i guess there's some queen f3
okay i'll take and win the bishop or
take the bishop and
just castle
[Music]
very important let's check otherwise i
got mated
never mind
um
i gotta move quicker oh let's enable the
extension
[Music]
arrow yes
save okay
i haven't used that extension in ages
no i'm losing a thing you are so slow
just go
go
oh
[Music]
down material and getting yelled at
not a great feeling
you chess coach andres hey it's andres
what's up andres
we have an andrus command
shout out to andres
you're gonna ah okay
if you're just joining i've been
streaming for
eight and a half hours
i'm down a piece here
but i'm going for comp
i have to apply maximum pressure
i assume andres was also playing this
tournament
the king should be here calculating
takes takes
and there's some eventual queen b3 check
okay so if we trade rooks
bring the queen back on h5
it's actually kind of tricky takes queen
here threatening this and this
and queens are very geometrical pieces
if pawn takes i
guess i play rook f3
i hope for the best
thank you snicker man
yeah follow andres
has great content on twitch and on
youtube
interesting
just go
okay we're simplifying a bit
b5
move the king
i want to win b2
easier said than done
might as well just improve everything
before i win stuff
or lose stuff
[Music]
messed up a little bit there
okay let's at least get my king in
and walk all the way up
might be able to
we've got three as a safe remove
what
was that move
was a free rook
that's not stalemate
let's check me okay
that's a nice maiden two
dicks and mate
okay
let's go
berserking win
plus one rating points
twelfth place
out of 15 000 almost people
everyone joined the tournament if people
haven't played you should play at least
one game
this could be the biggest chess
tournament in history
oh playing this opponent again
i feel like we had a good game earlier
forget exactly what happened
oh the opponent who offered me a draw
that that one game earlier
then i went on to win
i remember that game dude come on oh
okay
i don't know why i'm playing a job of
london
oh that's why because opponent played d6
and then d5
here we go
um
i mean queen f3
i do share this something similar in my
london course
you're gonna lose on time you donut
oh no one's ever called me a donut
before
i don't think
you gotta move come on make a move
maybe rook team one bishop b2
play bishop b2
i should probably delete this extension
at some point
not good for my mental health
[Music]
wait where's my
there we go okay
save there we go
just move just move you got no time no
i thought i deleted them
also free pawn
can you play any slower josh
i have this move
no i
have to refresh
save okay
should be good now
position is a little bit concerning
[Music]
is my
thing feels a bit tender
there's a funny line
so it takes takes bishop g4 queen g3
takes and then i take here
and both bishops are hanging
and black might be going into it
yeah so it takes takes and
wow 94.
uh
i mean i have to take that i think
speak with bishop
and then if pawn takes i've rooked e5
if bishop d1
[Music]
we could take with the knight on d5
it looks like there's adequate
compensation
calculations takes takes
i'll play rook d5
attacking defending
[Music]
and block wants to play this move
i'm thinking i just
leave my rook on d5
okay bishop e6 is coming
maybe i shouldn't leave my rook on d5
let's move
yeah i have to be careful now
[Music]
in knight t5 is a move
looks fun
getting a fork
takes takes
should take a break i've only taken one
break this whole stream
[Music]
and probably take another break also
free pawn
that's probably not entirely free let's
reinforce everything
ooh
f1 in the end
i think it's okay
like takes takes takes takes
at bishop c1
and maybe e3
or a3
a3
i gotta move quicker too
so this i have check and win the rook
that move i forgot about rt2 maybe
[Music]
enough one king a2
doesn't look good look at this move
attacking defending
wow
strong move i have this move no it
doesn't work
just this move
defending
writing this to attack everything
that's terrifying
trying to roll with the punches
i'm still threatening this
okay staying alive
kind of
i just want to trade a pair of rooks
and also play knight g5 and eventually
mate
that's all i want in life
green trade would be nice too
knight g5 may be coming
if bishop c2
[Music]
could be in trouble
no time to think
i think this maybe
things are falling now
that file is opened
i have this move
some pressure
these pawns are now attached
black is a little bit cocooned
thankfully i've worked out for one
otherwise queen g1 is winning
queen defends from a distance
this move
this thing's defended
confusing position
wow good move
i have to play this and pray
it takes the thing
anything mated
staying alive still kind of
i don't know how i'm still alive
i thought i'm supposed to be dead by now
okay that's how i die
tragic
very tragic finish
opponent didn't even on the son
found the other
legal move
good game though
it was good fights
okay
still working
[Music]
do people do that when i punch my green
screen
not really oh thank you zippy
i tried my best also thank you traverse
island subbing for one year good try
eric what a great battle
okay
playing the person in first
yeah h6 is a little bit tender
oh i didn't see my rook was hanging
i'm still trying to fight here
i have a bishop in pawn for rook
oh this is really bad
oh no my position
this move
[Music]
there's only one hole please take my
g-pawn please
really trying for the sail matrix
[Music]
there goes my king
what to do
opponent played well
probably should not have lost the rook
on a1
i went downhill pretty quickly
okay
let's redeem myself hopefully
what place is my opponent in
uh we had this line earlier
i got a nice position earlier too
[Music]
okay that's kind of scary
thanks for your youtube vids i please
given me lots of ideas to help improve
my chess hope this helps support what
you do your religion
really appreciate that thanks for the
ten dollars
that does help keep me awake a little
bit
um
take and win the night
mix with pawn okay so
i'm confused here
position should be good
might as well just go for the attack
i have queen f4
[Music]
i should probably play queen
f4 although i also have this move
for this move
i have no idea what's going on now i'm
probably worse but it's interesting
takes and check
idea of this
i think i'm getting mated yet
everything made in like three or four
[Music]
this is probably just
meeting yeah this is a meeting let's go
cookie two
okay
because white was running made in one
very
very end there
okay in 13th place
slowly but surely
berserk
hey it's one two three four five six
almost kind of i missed it
but it happened
just a moment ago
i wish i
was paying attention more closely
okay
opponent taking their time
yeah c5 is not a great move
this is already very pleasant
okay
like to stay focused
i don't know why i'm taking so long here
let's play knight b5
this is a really nice position
there's a funny line uh
rook here bishop c7
h697 bishop c8
um
preserve the bishop losing a pawn but
i think there's comp
actually after takes i take the rook and
check
96
i was going to take work to win good
evening from singapore you're doing
great champ
rock on thank you singapore back hammond
good evening
i usually don't stream
evening time in singapore
it's 6 27 a.m in the morning for me
if i'm down the pawn but
have the bishop hair have better
structure
also i don't have any increment so
that's kind of annoying
bishop d4 am
this is going to be really unpleasant to
play
might as well keep the rooks i guess
idea b4
i'd be okay with a draw here
unlocks grinding me down unfortunately
arguing with b4 probably
yeah i think it's winning
or is it
if it's winning
lock's not pre-moving which is
unfortunate
otherwise i would go for the h5 pre-move
trap
but
what to do
ah
opening was great i took a lot of time
like not sure how to maximize
the advantage
an ip5 one of the best moves
and this looked like a really nice line
bishop a6
ah bishop b7 is simpler
than just winning the pawn
and the bishop e5 makes sense okay
yeah let the advantage slip that game
still 13th place
all the work to do
oh i'm playing lance
okay
lance beats me usually
but let's play uh s
stafford or non-stafford
or stafford
okay going for stafford
oh this one reverse fried liver this is
actually a cool one
um take
what's going on here queen h4
go for this and
i'm down a piece but
go for something
this looks playable
got some pawns
i was about to blunder my queen there
blundering everything
okay i won't connect four though i have
this idea
[Music]
me too almost
almost set up the trick
ah well played
oh there's a chance for stalemate
please
okay i resigned
oh it's close
lance was good maybe next time i don't
berserk
have to show no mercy
oh playing this opponent again
does this look like berserk i forget
are they not berserk
i beat them in the uh queen versus
three minor pieces game
okay this is usually a pleasant line for
white
e4 c4
interesting move between c3
okay trading a bit
e5 might be coming
trying to calculate e5 and then
i b5 probably go for
i don't mind if the files open
f6 is coming
[Music]
the plan is to trade and then go for d4
unfortunately it might be slightly worse
here
maybe it's close to equal
this comes down to what happens on the
queen side
f3 there's f5
a6 i'm thinking b6
interesting
the king wants to come in
i'm in trouble
have this move
i don't think it works but might as well
try it
it doesn't work
black may have over pushed here actually
it looks like king c6 swinger
it's still probably losing for me but
it's kind of interesting now
because here i check
and take
play this
there's actually a really funny line
which
probably won't happen
i haven't calculated this but
it's probably just getting mated by
force
oh no
yeah i think it's it's probably just
losing there
oh i missed rook a4 no rogue for those
just takes
they're losing the whole time
yeah
yeah okay it's a nice resource
okay shall i wear the swan mask
someone mentioned it
oh erica amy
if i lose one more game i'll punish
myself by wearing the swan mask
i haven't worn it the whole stream
[Music]
or maybe i'll reward myself for being
such a fighter
also f3 staffer gambit
but with knight c3
interesting usually the pawn comes with
c3 in these lines
i'll castle and go for f5
so
[Music]
swan mask will be coming on shortly
yeah just plundered
i had to play some like queen d6 or
bishop b6 first i blundered a knight too
this is not my proudest game
[Music]
what if
i put on the mask
and then terrify my opponent
will that help
that will help okay
i can barely see
oh
[Music]
the mask is on
i'm now a swan
[Music]
you're the swan
oh wait ah
where's my mouse there's my mouse
back
i don't think this is gonna help
my head feels so uncomfortable
hey it's minlae says penguin
swans are distantly related to penguins
i think
this move
i don't know what's more
uncomfortable this mask or this position
oh
at least i'm up on time
for everyone just joining i'm now a swan
well that's a good move
i wanted to checkmate
this move
i can't even do my thinking pose because
the peak is in the way
okay so i'm down two
i wonder if my opponent is watching
right now
hello to my opponent
as well
oh no my pawn
or oh no my swan
[Music]
next level chess
okay
okay going for rook b5
i'm so tired i could probably fall
asleep in this thing
i'll be a sleeping
i really want to take and win
not so simple though
okay the swan is ready to bite
your swans even have teeth
that's a good move
[Music]
hmm
not the bishop
for the king
um
i'll have hope though
oh no
okay one more game one more game
the only way for me to take the mask off
is to win a game
also makes bigger
one slightly larger
a berserk
i can barely see
um
lamentation of eric's one sad swan noise
why do i make sad swan noises
i want to make happy swan
i'm up a lot of time let's go
foreign
um
[Music]
hey
let's go
i
so powerful
and so swan like
oh
okay
escaped
let's go
i was kind of dirty though that should
have been the draw
i probably should have lost
that i was getting kind of like dizzy in
that mask because it cuts
like it kind of suffocates me
but thankfully i'm still alive
13th place
lucky number 13.
it's pressure
and chess weeb
and even more people
okay playing queen g for this time
oh i'm not biz working
those pawns a bit tender
i think i'm gonna need to take a break
soon
i'm a little bit dizzy from that
previous game
[Music]
that was fun though
oh fun game
[Music]
as long as i keep winning i'll keep
streaming how about
okay taking would be blunderous
let's trade queens
ooh
this equal material
question is how to get out of this bind
three
h3
i'm going to take advantage of the fact
i have increments i have to think
like how do i play this for a win
an interesting dilemma
i already repeat twice
one
okay now
maybe king d1
hoping for king e5
all right let's put this on stack upon
the rook is almost trapped
oh
oh no i'm losing this
draw
i'm gonna lose this oh it's so bad
and black's getting confused
ah now i'm getting confused
it's a good move
work f3 is coming
um
i'm trying to calculate the stalemate
oh it's kind of intense
i think i have to play this
yes
no
ah
[Music]
i i did give my opponent time to think
but
i was trying to
save a hopeless position
[Music]
what to do
hey it's for ringing chess what's up
good to see you
yeah i'm a little bit tired but
um okay so here's how it works
if i lose one more game i drop out and i
get some rest
but if i keep winning i keep playing
yeah we have a stafford
that's a playable line for white
getting the pawn on h2
um
this is actually still prep
is it
look at this takes
here here here i trap the knight
my goal is to walk around and get into
the crevice
of white's territory
and this move's probably coming
idea a4
nom e3 maybe
it's kind of risky
it's kind of risky
maybe i can just leave the tension
like king a5 and b5
stucco angel says jude i went to sleep
seven hours ago and you're still here
yeah that's how
[Music]
physics works
i don't move away i still
[Music]
am in my current position
okay uh let's try and focus on this move
i have a bad feeling i'm gonna get mated
somehow with my king
here but now
[Music]
what's the worst that can happen knight
comes with c2
this position confuses me
i think i want to play this in this
i have a g5 too
to assert my dominance
i don't see any reason not to play g5
uh the knight wants to do things okay so
let's
i see lights plan
it's hard to stop
oh very very clever
i'll play this
i think i'm just in time though
because here i have this move
and b4 will be coming
okay so i got my things
my pawns are doing things
pawns are actually controlling a lot of
squares here
again still trying to play for a win
it's a hard nut to crack
it's like one of those
chestnuts
need to find a nutcracker
did this move
i could pull a fabiano and just sack
like his game against rey
i mean what else to do
okay i was hoping for a pre-move but
it's still probably drawn
oh wow
if i take
it doesn't work
i feel like there's a decent chance i'll
end up losing this so i should probably
bail out for a draw now
[Music]
oh i still have the chance
the other idea would be to provoke white
to over push
which would be kind of funny
like d4 and d4 might be a good move
that white has no risk of losing now
i don't think i have too much risk of
losing either
wow so wait's playing for it
for all the great chess and goose
related content eric
oh thank you
armanides
am i in trouble here i'm probably in
some trouble
yeah i'm in trouble
[Music]
or am i at this move
if i win the pawn
i restrict the knight and end too
in knight d3 i have to play this
and this is kind of what i wanted like
just like games you go on
and
there's still chances to win
weirdly enough i think you cauliflower
the prime sub
yeah we're at the nine and a half hour
mark
opponent now
in the tank
i mean knight d3
i can't take because after this there's
b4 winning for white
knight d3 i can play this move
and then there's a calculation knight
before takes takes
i take here
i don't think is winning
it might be losing actually
i might have to settle for repetition
[Music]
i have this move if i really want to
play for a win
[Music]
how bad is this move
it looks pretty bad because king d4
[Music]
but it's a move
okay we'll settle for a draw
and this is this
okay that's a draw
the final position positions just to
draw was there a draw the whole time
[Music]
avoid ever better
i think it was just to draw the whole
time we're going to see a flat line for
a part of that game
thank you jordy mcgeort shorts
it's resilient
i'm still awake kind of
unless i'm like sleep streaming and this
is just my
unconsciousness talking
why was winning in this position
king d3
it's actually very logical
the king d yeah king d3 and
you see four starts to stop
okay well i didn't lose
i drew
okay how about this
i'll berserk until i lose and then i
finish so this could be my last game
especially if my opponent doesn't
booster back
and now i'm in a must-win situation
this player beat me earlier too
[Music]
i'm kind of asking to get dirty flagged
here
against the one and only
getting this now
it looks pleasant those pawns are weak
no offense to the pawn
i want to play knight d6 now
this pawn's also weak no offense
ah this one's weak
what's going on though
that's kind of interesting
because this pawn is gonna fall
i'm temporarily down
[Music]
i'm trying to win the queen
that's running the rook
i'm not even up a pawn yet
i should be up upon soon
it's probably not a great move
i don't know who's playing for a win
anymore
i think i'm still playing for a win
the vlog's probably playing for a win
now
[Music]
oh no i'm getting made by force
that's so sad
ah
oh the each pawn was poisonous
also i was flagging
oh what to do
time to sleep
it's still drawn but it's slightly
unpleasant
especially after getting needed
okay
didn't quite make it to top 10. let's
pause
finish in 13th
maybe i'll wake up at some point
hopefully and then finish the tournament
but yeah sleep is important
nine hours and 41 minutes into the
stream
if you're watching in the future on
youtube
congratulations for making this video
eric smile
again comment your favorite part of the
stream
if you're watching on twitch feel free
to make clips
just like g space
thank you chris lebadeb
yeah i appreciate everyone who subbed
and
supported and cheered
etc
you uh
whoa it's just dojo ah
do i play one more game for just dojo
i was just about to wrap up
my almost 10 hour stream
[Music]
what a time to read i'll play one more
just for chess dojo
i'm back in the tournament i was i've i
said if i lose i retire but okay
berserking
playing gregory
let's go for this thing
oh
my knight
hey
someone call an ambulance
but not for me
okay now we can end halfway my friend
nfds brags about his 4-0 against you on
tt nfds1 toast
wait what about toast
something toast
okay that's a nice way to end things
how did i start the stream
i started the stream wait let me find
the first game i played this stream
it's gonna require going back
but
that's an especially funny way
to end the stream because
wait for it
wait for it wait for it wait for it
i played a lot of games this stream
okay so is this game
my first game of the stream
was this line
the oh no my queen line
so i got this one
and this one
a five move one that was so great
okay i feel so accomplished now
i did have a bucket list
this was on my bucket list too as an
england gambit trap i think
england gamut trap
accomplished
okay
so now i can sleep happily hello to
future youtube people
be sure to subscribe
or off if you're on twitch you can also
subscribe
um
yeah thanks everyone i appreciate the
support the viewership the moral support
the bits
the subs the followers
the emotes
oh let's pause the tournament before i
accidentally start another game